the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess
club stunning sacrifices were met with
Sterling defense at the St Louis rapid
and Blitz despite players taking Dynamic
risks nearly every battle ended in a
fighting draw leader Liam lay kept
swinging for the fences in an effort to
expand his lead but eventually struck
out against Fabiano caruana losing after
two close draws this left the door open
for a Victorious Ray Robson to catapult
into to clear first place after getting
his second win with players in Peak form
the margins for error are thinner than
ever day three of razor sharp chess
coming up
[Music]
next
welcome to day three of the S Louis
rapid in Blitz it's the last day of
Rapid portion let's see what players
have in store let's go to the studio and
find
[Music]
out welcome to St Louis the home of CH
in America as the St Louis chess club
proudly presents St Louis rapid and blit
the final day of Rapid starts right
now hello and welcome everyone this is
day three of the St Louis rid and Blitz
I'm International Master t s alongside
me as always the one and only grandm Yas
Saran and grandm P hello hello indeed
day two had us on the edge of our seats
it was really it's going to be a fun day
of Chess it was a dramatic dramatic uh
day two as we had two rounds of all
draws but that third and final round of
the day was really explosive the Wild
Card players have outperformed Liam Lee
uh kept the lead through five rounds but
he faltered against Fabby to open the
door for Ray Robson another wild card
player in clear first Tanya do the
honors and tell our audience who's
leading and yes it all comes down to
today the final three days of the rapid
the final three games of rapid and there
we have it going into around seven
leading the pack is Ray Robson and
trailing close with seven points three
players Maxim vasher lra Anish Ki and
Liam Le the wild cards continue to
impress Ali Resa fuja who had to suffer
a loss in day which has seen him go down
in the standings has to come back into
form today for a big finish and I'm
looking at Wesley so at the very bottom
of the Cross table that is so unusual to
see we'll see if he can bounce back tell
us about the format for this competition
it's an incredibly fun format we saw
there we've got four wild cards and
that's what I love about the tournament
as well you've got the heavy weights
you've got the big names and fighting
amongs amongst them is Ray Robson Assan
sa and Liam impressing us all and this
is the action that's coming up with the
players again getting to my starting
with 25 minutes on the clock a 10-second
increment we have three games of Rapid
the final three games it's two points
for a win a point for a draw zero for a
loss and then tomorrow things switch up
absolutely while rapid ends Blitz begins
tomorrow it will be a double round robin
in the blitz traditional points system
of one win for a win half a point for
the draw the players get five minutes
per side for the game and every time
they complete their move by pressing
their clock they'll get two second bonus
no draw offers throughout this
competition tell us about the remaining
schedule let's take a look we are in
Daye three once again the final day of
the rapid tomorrow we switch it up with
uh day one off the Blitz it's going to
be 18 games in total for the blitz a
double round robin the players play each
other twice with reversed colors so
there's still a lot of Chess to be
played a lot of points to be earned 18
points to be exact in the blitz but
thanks to the double rounds today six
points up for grabs Peter wonderful to
have you in studio tell us here tell us
about the road ahead for these uh
leaders absolutely we have a leading
group of four players so let's take a
look what awaits them today starting
with our our former leader Liam Le who
lost his last round game and is now tied
for second as you can see on your screen
he has a very very tough working day
ahead black against ala FIA black
against Yan pomnish and a white game
against mvl alza is not having a
particularly Stellar tournament so far
but this is a very very tough
lineup uh after him we have Anish giri
also tied for second uh Anish starts
with the two white games which is an
easier schedule White against Jeffrey
Shong White against Fabian Karana and
also playing alira fuja in the last
round another player tied for second is
Maxim Vash gra uh who we will see on our
screens uh next with another very very
tough schedule uh of course this is a
very strong tournament so nobody's going
to have it easy but I think a slightly
uh softer uh schedule potentially uh as
as soon as soon as we I like the graphic
SP yeah I I I I understand the the
temptation to always look at Anish like
looking at Anisha is many's people's
favorite pastime but at some point we
should maybe uh get mvl up on screen
there he is the handsome devil uh White
against Ray Robson black against Liam Le
and then white against samian in the
last round and on that note we come to
our tournament leader uh Ray Robson who
is in pole position on eight out of 12
so far playing against mvl then uh
against Yan pishi and ending the the day
black against Wesley so once again in a
a veritable murderous row of of
opponents for today and there he is on
your screen getting ready for uh this uh
round and we also have in studio uh our
fourth and final commentor absolutely
and we we would like to throw it over to
woman gas Anastasia kovich with more
news about our wonderful
tournament hello Peter hello yaser and
I'm so glad to be here with you today
and actually yesterday we had a very
unexpected result at the end end of the
day Anish giri managed to win against
Sam S and how he won this game he Sam
lost on time and after that Anish true
to himself published a post in Instagram
account so let's have a look what did he
say yeah so Anish now we see him on the
screen and now we can see his post we'll
keep wearing my hoodie until security
removes me what did he mean by this post
what did he threaten actually to all of
us uh infectious players are very
superstitious people and sometimes they
have their rituals and habits during the
tournament so I think he believed that
the hoodie brought him luck yesterday
and uh he actually wanted to keep wear
he threatened us that he would keep
wearing it until the end of the
tournament but look no it didn't happen
today andish changed his hoodie and um
appeared in a different outfit so it
seems that Anish is not so superstitious
as he promised to be yesterday
so with this finny note let me remind to
all our viewers not to forget to
subscribe to our social media accounts
um Grand chest stour St Louis chess club
are waiting for you as well as they're
waiting for Yer sarahan and I think now
it's time to get back to the studio to
you guys Anastasia I'm your biggest fan
come on come on of course of course I
I'm going to join you bet you bet in the
meanwhile in the meanwhile in the hood
with a new hoodie yeah I saw that that
looked pretty good actually I did I get
a hoodie I didn't get a hoodie he got
his game on and with that wind that he
had yesterday I think uh he can also
feel that perhaps the luck is switching
today it's time to go all in and he is
tied for a second tell us about the
pairings uh coming up Tanya a lot of
Juicy matchups on the way ASA this is
where we are Ali Resa fera who had one
of the most creative games that we saw
in day two but also suffered a
heartbreak is playing a very important
game against Liam Le uh Liam Le
currently tied for second place Maxim
vasher lra plays the tournament leader
if we see on paper Maxim a big favorite
if he takes down Ray Robson things can
really switch up in our standings Anish
gir we saw there with a brand new hoodie
plays against Jeffrey Jong and then
we've got fabulous Fabby against well
some stunning chess by Sam Sean Sam
could easily be one sporting a
seven-point result but that uh loss on
the clock yesterday that was just a real
real shock and it's so difficult to get
over those moments as well because he's
the one who's pushing against the
opponent he's up in exchange against
Anish giri Sam savan uh and then the
heartbreaking flagging that happened but
that's part of the game that is part the
clock is the 17th piece and Sam just
somehow missed out on it and he starts
with a big game black pieces against the
world number two Fabiano Carana and
Peter I think you had a excellent
explanation as to why Sam Actually lost
that game on time cuz he got this
opportunity to go into King and pawn end
game which he was analyzing analyzing
analyzing it in a way it was very
unlucky for him because uh for many
moves until that moment he really had
nothing to calculate so he was very
securely Making Moves In the all the
time and then that opportunity to maybe
win on the spot if it works out was
presented to him and he burned all of
his time trying to figure out if it
actually does work and we yes we y and
on the board by Maxim VRA 1 C4 the
English and that has taken me by
surprise and it's taken Ray Robson by
surprise it certainly has and uh Ray
saying just a second what is it about my
repertoire that you're trying to get me
to play and the problem the only problem
I ever had with English is white 1 C4 is
it does give black an opportunity to get
a foothold in the center with E5 I've
always thought that that is the most
challenging answer to the English and uh
Ray agrees uh the four nights have
become increasingly popular and it's
this move E2
E4 uh kind of taken this tournament a
little bit by storm hasn't it uh Peter
we've only had the pure English with E4
once and as you can see uh yeah I have I
have a different game on the screen
there but yeah mvl does not play for
plays G3 which is by far the the most
popular move in this position and the
move that most people
uh play here we'll see how Ray reacts I
think these days most people have
included the English as part of their
repertoire because it gives you an
opportunity perhaps to avoid some of the
more sort of heavily contested
theoretical uh openings that you get if
you play E4 or D4 and move one uh Ray
clearly didn't expect C4 but he will
have a repertoire against it so exactly
I assume he will know what he's doing
he's just as you said trying to figure
out where he is being caught exactly
what is mvl expecting him to do and how
to maybe
Bishop B4 one of the most traditional
moves D7 D5 I've always kind of felt was
the most challenging but Bishop B for
yeah and the reason why we slowed down
and while why we were surprised with
Maxim's choice to start with the English
is because we've often seen him start
with the King's Pawn opening and
sometimes with the Queen's Pawn opening
it feels more his style of play
especially one E4 he's known to be an
aggressive ttian uh so this is
definitely interesting to see this
opening approach trying to get R out of
any preparation that he might have had
for this one and we see Maxine continues
to Blitz out the moves he's got more
time on the clock that he started with
yeah KN D5 uh I have essayed this move
uh so I'm not going to say it's uncommon
what's the theoretical value of this
move these days uh Peter I think mainly
the the old line starting with Bishop G2
castles castles have been analyzed into
dust to such a degree that people are I
think switching up to 95 and 95 lines
can at some in some cases get really
really wild there's a lot of a lot of
excitement potentially starting with
white putting the Knight on H4 and then
often just leaving it there for black to
win with the move G7 G5 right uh so if
that is where we had it which is
entirely possible we could have a very
very fun first game uh to start us off
on the right foot wonderful as we uh let
this on the boil let's just go around
and take a look at perusia uh versus
Liam again Liam kind of upset that uh
he's coming into today's round not as
the tournament leader losing against
fabbi that position I mean it always
felt like three results but maybe Liam
was the favorite too it really felt like
a game that Liam should not have lost
not only given the position but his form
as well he's been so precise this
tournament converting good positions
holding solid positions uh but we saw a
bit of a collapse there just a couple of
moves where which were inaccurate one
after the other and then Fabby was on
top of it a much needed win by Fabby
that one and Liam has to face Ali Resa
fuja exactly who despite the loss
yesterday has been in form in this
tournament and we do see that it started
with the Spanish opening the Berlin in
this case and uh D2 D3 Bishop takes C6
uh again the players are in heavy
theoretical uh territory I just want to
say for those of you who missed
yesterday I fully agree with Tanya who
said that f 's game with Wesley so was
the game at the tournament I mean that
was just an incredible game he
sacrificed his Queen for two minor
pieces it looked like just he was just
at the winning post Peter I want to say
when he slipped and he let uh Wesley
also defended really really well so much
much of the credit must go to Wesley
there who kept on muching him blow for
blow but yeah that was a fantastic
fantastic game to to watch and to try
and get get some sense of I've always
felt that that just on that note about
yesterday's game Peter what you said a
lot of credit goes to Wesley that the
most beautiful games in chess are made
up when both players play to the best of
their ability it's not about a one-sided
game where you sacrifice you attack you
win the game and when your opponent
shows some incredible resourcefulness
that's when you get a masterpiece
exactly that was Jim taran's idea that
the brilliancy price should have been
shared I mean as was a creative effort
of two players uh even though this uh
position is the theoretically uh
disputed I want to say um what is the
what's the exact winning percentages
here for the players Peter it seems like
yeah I'm I'm very bad with these stats
white should probably be slightly ahead
here this this type of structure lens
itself I think it's it's rather equal
but white should normally win a bit more
than black but the interesting thing
here is there are 350 games that reach
this position okay none here none here
none here this is a completely Fresh
Approach here by lza which frankly at
first I had to check that I'm not
mistaken because one thing yeah one
thing that white does not have here is a
light squared bishop and there is this
bishop over over on C8 which could land
on H3 and normally you you don't do this
very much because it it weakens the
whole the whole light Square complex on
on the king side but clearly white is
intending to put the King on G2 perhaps
Knight H4 push for F4 uh and this
somehow works out ala clearly has not
done this by a misclick he means to play
this but still it's a very striking new
idea in a very very well researched
position I wanted to say as a chess
coach if uh my student comes and plays
G3 I give a long long lecture never do
that when you don't have a light Square
that's a remarkable move G3 brand new
position on move number nine yeah
totally new approach we saw a very
creative Sacrifice by Ali Resa on day
two and I think this is a very creative
opening approach by him and as you're
mentioning the key Point why G3 is
something that feels so anti- positional
is because white doesn't have that light
squat Bishop put a bishop on G2 and
you've got a normal position way you go
but this is not something you get to see
every day and again I I would say unless
you're o Resa don't try this at home
right uh well we'll see uh how this
works out for him it sure is a
confounding move and in their
head-to-head matchups T wow ooh
it doesn't get more level than that it
doesn't right 15 games to boot in Rapid
chess between ala fuja and Liam five
wins five losses five draws for me I'm a
little bit surprised that they have so
much experience against each other I'm
wondering where they got those 15 games
from Peter probably the the rapid and
Blitz World Championships with some
maybe grun chest to thrown in because
Li gets gets wild cards occasionally
yeah but you don't really play him as
often ala will will not get the volume
against liml the kind of volume he gets
against the other top players but as as
the screen suggests he knows he's in for
five he he knows he's playing somebody
who is very very capable as we go to uh
some of the other games just take a
break this down this position for us uh
both players have played A4 A5 D6 why
trying to jle four for space on the
queen side these are just sort of
General useful moves uh a
5 I was a bit surprised this was the
first the first thought that came to uh
Le's mind there but just generally
slightly improving a situation on the
queen side is not bad sometimes the
bishop comes out to A6 you can maybe
imagine some scenarios where this bishop
Retreats or gets traded and you put the
bishop on B7 play C6 C5 use the the long
diagonal for for the light Square Bishop
but mainly I think these are improving
moves which are also very non-committal
MH you perhaps don't want to play F7 F6
so early you would like as we as we
mentioned the bishop on C8 would like
maybe to go to H3 right but the problem
for black is that you cannot currently
play something like Knight f8 because
you E5 Pawn is hanging whoops uh and the
way to solve it would be to play F6 but
this move makes some of White's play
easier because the queen is no longer so
active you you feel more comfortable
maybe playing Knight F4 Knight Knight H4
Knight F5 and so on so uh players are so
far unwilling to commit to any serious
structural changes and this is a way to
spend a couple of temp slightly
improving a position without really
telling your opponent what you're
intending to do further bance position
Peter probably yeah yeah okay let's
continue our Look Around the Horn we're
going to jump to Anish giri versus uh
Jeffrey Jang and well looks like I dare
I say it
Fisher uh okay we do have a nidorf on
the board but A2 A4 I don't know what
this particular variation the night of
is called do you I'm not sure about what
the name is but I've always really
enjoyed seeing these top players play
these slightly offbeat ideas in speed
chess and I think that's really
instructive because it's so difficult
for the opponent uh to find the correct
response it might not objectively be the
most aggressive or the most correct
option or something that is played
regularly but it just gets you out of
theoretical books and then you have to
go into a think tank yourself and often
burn critical amount of time right which
later on comes to haunt you so it's a
really good concept of having certain
openings which are different from your
usual reper for Rapid chess indeed uh
because just as you say you don't have
so much time to solve the problems that
are being put in front of you like you
do in classical chest after the move E7
E5 the knight uh drops back to
F3 and because the pawn is now on E5 the
move Bishop C4 becomes that much more
attractive as we're about to see because
again we do have an outpost and uh well
Anish is uh covering it Rook CA Bishop
pardon me uh B2 B3 Queen A5 check
B4 um I'm out of my depth certainly uh
here and uh I'm really having a bit of a
senior moment here because I was I was
absolutely certain this is my game
against Alexander grishuk from the World
Cup in 2011 that I won where I won the
first game of the four game match with
black and immediately switched to making
draws with white of course and I want to
say that this is a line you play to have
very very little risk and I think Sasha
this being game two out of four chose
not to you know fight it very very hard
and it went like this and we traded on
the six and somewhere around here I
offered a draw and that draw was agreed
but the database disagrees with me
violently and says it's not there that
game does not exist apparently uh so I'm
mixing up something but I'm not entirely
sure what uh Queen A5 check is an
interesting option here because the
trade of Queens probably is completely
fine for black and B3 B4 is a very
committal move because as we've seen in
the game you now have to waste another
Tempo retreating with the bishop and A6
A5 is also incredibly logical you would
very much like to spoil white structure
on the queen side if you're allowed to
take on B4 in white recaptures with a
piece it's very good for black the
question is whether we can play C3 mhm
it does not blunder that pawn because
after Bishop D5 Queen D5 F7 is hanging
so you have no time to pick up on C3 but
it's it's very concrete so far I would
say honestly I like what jeffre is doing
really really uh is it a novel approach
by the way from Jeff Queen A5 I don't I
mean as you get there's still there's
still some games there there's a game
between for instance between gakamsky
and Vin tapalo from way back in 2011 so
this has been seen before but it's
reasonably rare and another layer to
this game of course is that Anish uh did
a course on the night from the black
side right so Jeffrey is doing uh
something that what's your opinion on
playing uh a player's signature opening
against them were you a fan of that in
your playing career or no no I know that
David brunstein was a fan of that
approach for me no why am I walking into
your prep Tanya I'm not going to give
you you the the the position that you
want to play I'm going to try to take
you out of the positions you feel
comfortable and I know there are players
that enjoy the challenge if you will
entering your territory definitely this
part to it but there's also for for
instance in my experience when people
play the grinfield against me I very
often would just sit there after move
three and and think you know I can play
20 different things right but in my mind
all of them are fine for black right
because I you know as a as a DI died in
the wo grinfield player you know I feel
like everything is fine for black in
thefield so
I'm just sitting there completely unable
to choose and honestly I think it's
sometimes a pretty decent choice just to
say to Anish okay refute your own
opening here please and and see what he
does this doesn't really look like a
reputation of his own opening I'm I'm
going to be entirely fair I I think B
should be fine I would agree with Yer
it's quite Brave to step into your
opponent's territory where they've spent
years studying the opening and
challenging trying to challenge them in
that but a really nice uh idea there by
Jeffrey Jong with the queen check
provoking white to create weaknesses on
the queen side which can be targeted
with the a pawn and then moving back and
while uh we have the players take a
think let's take everyone our audience
inside the World Chess Hall of Fame our
playing Hall where the magic happens yes
absolutely well this of course is the
third floor of the World Chess Hall of
Fame on the lower floors the first and
second floors they have these wonderful
exhibits and they're on a uh floor uh
reserved completely for them player uh
pardon me uh Spectators are not allowed
in uh the fair play uh the players have
their own um I want to say uh Lounge
area where they have the uh the uh
monitors and they can see when it's
their move or not they also have a
kitchen area where they can get all of
the drinks restrooms and everything
so uh the hall is white enough large
enough to accommodate as many as 16
tournament games and these uh
Furnishings that you see that the chess
boards are especially made here from a a
local Master Craftsman they've got that
yeah beautiful padded uh place so you
can put your elbows it's nice it's a
it's you you you feel like you're in a
professional setting it it's inspiring
to be there and to play there five
boards we saw set up there and the
opening ceremony happened there as well
with the players drawing of lots uh so
if you're in St Louis definitely head
over to the World Chess Hall of Fame
what is your opinion about having
Spectators in the playing Hall did you
enjoy it when you had a crowd watching
you I loved it I love it too love
absolutely loved it and uh I remember
very much the old days of the Soviet
Union you would go into these uh
tournament venues which would just be
standing room only and the crowds would
make noise as the play ERS would
sacrifice oo and AZ and you know the
Arbiters get up and go silence silence
and I'm sitly going let the audience o
and oo and o I love that feedback to you
Peter do you prefer the quietude that
the players have or no I I I regret I I
think we all understand why uh the
current roles are in place but it's it's
regrettable toe I think it's much better
to play to a live audience you feel you
feel much more involved you feel yeah
it's
a I think as with all and we are to to a
degree entertainers you would like to
see who exactly you're entertaining
hopefully uh so yeah on the other hand
of course with with uh the how strong
the engines have become and how small
the devices have become it's it's very
understandable that you don't want to
create even uh a suspicion of something
on towards going onward going on but
regrettable it is regrettable yeah I
think playing with with people watching
is just better Peter another game has
caught your attention what game are you
looking at this is a game between Fabi
on the white side against Sam seian who
uh hopefully had some time to recover
from that extremely unfortunate end his
game against Anish gir yesterday right
still all 32 player pieces on the board
this has been a a Joko piano which uh
actually is a Joo Pi with not very much
going on uh outwardly at least a very
kind of a classical approach where white
goes before 4 A4 and then there is a
just Ling for position in the center and
the current situation why did achieve
the D3 D D4 move which we were talking
about I think on one of the earlier days
that right it still is very much part of
White's plans but black on the other
hand uh got a a very nice looking night
on the four there and white still needs
to show what exactly it is that you're
intending and yeah fa Fab goes Knight C4
which is a very logical move but a move
that invites the question let's say can
we immediately go ed4 and follow it up
with D6 D5 next move just to resolve the
situation in the center and see see
what's happening which could lead to
very sharp positions of course I'm
probably inclined to recapturing with
the Knight unless I'm allowing Queen G5
I'm still I'm still going to try to play
D5 against most of your options I think
right uh because I think it just gives
me uh I don't like allowing this Knight
on C4 to stand there for too long
because uh one thing to to watch out for
if if you do nothing here B5 B6 could be
a very annoying move to allow because
the PA D6 is weak so this is why I was
trying to uh resolve that issue
immediately to the degree that even this
I would have to ask myself am I worried
about this or not and the answer is
probably no right but you have to you
have to figure out
why so this is what I'm expecting but
I'm not at all sure this is the only way
to approach this position Sam might have
an entirely different ideas you can play
something like Queen of6 right and say
show me what you got yeah if you want to
play B6 it's on your head go for it
eventually the bishop will probably come
out probably probably Tanya for me I'm
looking at this uh pairings and I'm
saying how is it possible that Yan and
Wesley so are not vying for first how
how can that not be our Marquee matchup
these two great players uh wow uh been
in the world's top top top for so long
and yet there they are they're
languishing and let's see what they have
again it looks like a Berlin but it's
not actually this is a traditional
morphe defense ruie Lopez with A7 A6 and
it's the uh deferred although I must say
it almost looks like the Ali Raza game
with D3 and the bishop on C5 yeah all of
these things kind of flow into each
other spiritually so to speak and this
this has actually become quite
fashionable this uh this way of playing
the bishop D six on move six variations
and uh a very strong players have been
looking into this recently I think with
the intention of having something new to
do against the Spanish exactly well we
do at least have a majority for white in
the king side in the center four versus
three uh majority for black on the queen
side except the pawns are double so it's
not easy to create a candidate uh passer
C6 C5 C4 on Wesley's agenda he's got the
two Bishops after all and lots of
maneuvering and somehow a little bit
passive maneuvering if you ask me Tanya
I mean queen went to E2 to D2 to C1 I
don't see this as a success for Yan I
don't think so either I think black
should be very very happy with the
results of the opening the big question
here is whether you can actually open
diagonals in particular for the bishop
on B7 which is why I've been looking at
the move of6 F5 in pretty much every
single position here the question for me
is if we play F5 immediately perhaps
white gets enough time to play C2 C4 and
then and then the other Bishop gets a
bit stuck yeah
this this is very very double-edged it
gives up a lot of squares for black in
the center honestly I don't know what
the engine will uh will say and for now
I don't even want to ask I want to
discuss it with you yeah I want to
discuss it with you from a purely human
perspective I think if I had this with
black I would think it's time for me to
start looking for maybe for ways to be
better exactly I'd be overjoyed as well
yeah I mean I would definitely like be
Ro rah rah rah rooting for myself uh it
seems like Wesley has gone a a third way
not C4 not F5 put the Knight on D4 I
assume with the intention of recapturing
with the pawn this is a bit surprising
to me because it allows white this way
to create create a break between the the
black will very much like to play C7 C5
of course and connect the pawns back
again of course but B before stops that
you are left with the F5 break which
still exists but in this position with a
bishop on B6 so completely out of play
I'm much more happy about this with
white suddenly yeah with B2B I I I've
been pining for C5 C4 uh for so long
could he be no there would be no reason
to recapture with the rook and love
Bishop F2 you might even lose the pawn
on C that's all wrong so a third and how
do they match up uh with these two
players Tanya let's take a look Yana
pomi and Wesley so who haven't impressed
us so far in the St Louis rapid and
Blitz have played each other a bunch of
times but it is Wesley so who leads and
I see see that has surprised you the
result between them is seven wins to Yan
12 losses against uh Wesley when I think
of yan I think of an absolutely superb
Blitz and Rapid player and uh that 12
to7 I know Wesley's very good too but I
did not expect that one-sided uh uh I
think that maybe flows over from their
results in classical because they they
have this very uh well publicized at
least uh for who are looking for these
types of studs they have this
storied uh I really hate the the storied
history sequence of wordss but I I'm
forced to use it now uh I think Yan lost
the first four or first five games he
played against Wesley in classical wow
and if that happens to you I think it
starts influencing all other formats as
well you don't recover so easily uh but
we do have that situation on the board
with B2 B4 I want to go back to the game
of Fabby for for just a moment because I
think he did get in the move that you
thought might be D dicey uh b six and if
you don't mind I'd love to see what the
engine thought about that that uh
getting in that wedge engine is not in
love with this and uh just says we can
now take on E5 right uh just going back
for a second currently the pawn on B6 is
hanging because black wants to take on
C4 and then take on B6 with the queen
but did take C5 I think stops that
together because if you if you go into
this end
game no uh if you go into this end game
you are probably not getting that Bishop
out and with the bishop rook and with
the bishop those two pieces are just out
of the game this looks borderline loss
to my eyes because really how are you
supposed
to get get them back into the game so
yeah you are perhaps uh more or less
forced to do something like this just to
keep the structure less symmetrical but
this also looks incredible incredbly
dangerous something like queen3 or
queen and it's a position it's a
position which on a bad day might not be
recoverable Rook ad D1 then the bishop
might drop back to C1 finally Ki kick
out the Knight on F4 the bishop on C4 is
very strong if you play D6 D5 once again
you're opening up a position in which
your two pieces are still in the corner
with no moves I don't like what Sam has
done here I I don't know if there were
real problems with what I was suggesting
but this do look right yeah this feels
like play on one goal I mean for sure
there um could he does he have a
different approach after B6 Bishop back
takes on E5 could he be angling for D5
96 is very strong it feels like you're
you're just in trouble it it does but I
hate that other variation that you said
where the pawn on as long as that pawn
on B6 lives that Bishop on B8 is stuck
and The Rook on A8 it's uh is equally
stuck so this feels like perhaps we can
we can we can say that uh the my
suggestion of he takes D4 I just brief I
briefly switch the engine on it does say
B5 B6 is quite strong here really which
I thought was possible but I kind of
refused to refuse to believe it but it
is the first engine suggestion and it
gives white a sizable Edge but honestly
I still prefer this to what Sam has done
because here I feel there's a much
better chance to get some kind of a mess
for instance I was looking at something
like this okay we are we are sacrificing
an exchange but we are left with all of
our pieces on the board we currently
have two pawns for the exchange Bishop
yeah and hopefully some play on the king
side eventually uh so yeah a bit
surprising that he he chose this and not
have been because of that that it was
the moment to actually not take on D4 or
the option and I was wondering if
there's a choice for black to actually
strike in the center immediately with D5
before you managed to get your move B6
in because I feel B6 and maybe I'm just
losing a pawn I'll have to like see C3
is attacked as well in some positions
you won't take with a knight here right
it's um it gets complicated but when
you're playing Black in these positions
you really don't want that dark squar
Bishop to have no future at all and I'm
just wondering if this was the moment
that Sam had to break free with a
central break and I would want to see
what the computer has to say about D5 if
it's not a oh it doesn't work doesn't
like it no doesn't like it either and
that takes on
D5 if we just go back yeah e takes D5 he
takes D5 it says you actually just have
to give up on E5 and play this not part
of the plan yeah but this is probably
maybe things have gone wrong for black
already then and Fabiano Karana he's
such an expert in these kind of
positions and it looks like he's got
exactly what he wanted we've had moves
he's got the bishop pair going black
still struggling with development notice
that Rook on A8 notice that Bishop on B8
still far away from activity perhaps
this is fabby's dream position with
white and he has a dream position in the
grandchester standings as well uh he
leads with that win in the Super bet
classic and coming up next is one of the
most popular chess tournaments one of
the most famous chess tournaments of the
calendar uh it is the sink field cup
which starts right after the St Louis
rapid and Blitz it will be the final
event of the grand Chester season 23 to
Crown the eventual winner yeah we will
have two wild cards as uh one ding Lin
is not in uh St Louis for this one and
let's take a look at the Grand chestor
standings as we're wrapping up at the
fourth event fifth event coming up and
Fabby looking fabulous fabulous Fabby
right at the top and notice not just the
GCT points not just the amount of money
that he's won but the events played
because that's the key here in the
grandchester season 23 the players have
to play a total of four events Fabby has
played only two which gives him an
additional two events which is going to
be the rapid and Blitz and the singfield
cup which means more points to be earned
so fa looking good at the top and right
now looking good with the white pieces
exactly I'm just looking at the game of
Fabi versus uh Sam for a moment because
it's not a tactic that you're often
seeing uh Fabby is enjoying a very nice
position again we're talking about The
Rook on A8 the bishop on B8 as being
laggards uh you want to get rid of this
Knight so you're attracted to the move
Queen f three attacking the Knight as
well as Queen G4 and the move Queen G4
actually falls for a very unusual tactic
you don't see that tactic very often
right it took me a few seconds but it's
a really nice idea that you're pointing
at exactly that takes you too where does
that come from and when you see a queen
and a king lined up on the same file
that's when your Spidey senses have to
go off you have to start looking for
these kind of motives exactly and no
matter how you recapture whether it be
with the queen and or with the King Rook
G5 comes and uh
well pins the queen to the king um
what's caught your attention Peter I'm
looking through uh through all the games
and just uh trying to see if something
dramatic happened everywhere anywhere
and uh this is the game between Anish
and Jeffrey and I think Jeffrey is just
completely fine I was somewhat shocked
somewhere around here uh we left it
after A5 yeah and Anish played Queen D2
a b Queen takes B4 my initial reaction
was this has to be a bit better for
black such a wonderful Knight on C5
looks fantastic the engine actually
prefers this for white a little bit wow
which was very unexpected to my eyes
counter intive for sure the game very
much uh equalized By this
point because uh Jeffrey correctly I
think just traded the B7 Pawn for the A5
pawn and what we have on the board now
should be very very level yeah uh of
course if you can imagine the white on
F3 being teleported over to D5 it takes
it takes a knight from F3 to D5 famously
if it's a diagonal two two square
diagonal move for the Knight takes four
moves yes so that's probably not going
to happen you have
to at least not very quickly yeah right
but if it got on D5 I mean white is just
clearly dominating black has to really
struggle for the rest of the game that
would be that would be good but it's not
going to happen and in fact the PA on C4
is somewhat vulnerable because right as
as very often the case the moment you
move the KN away from the F3 Square it
opens up opens up a very very important
Square for the bishop on F6 and you
could be in a bit of trouble here with
right so Anish will have to perhaps take
a bit of care in the next I don't know
five moves but I expect this to be
around equal for the remainder of if
from this current position if you go
Queen C8 Rook C8 Rook A4 for just a
moment one of the unusual Parts about
this specific position is the move D6 D5
you're you're not supposed to be able to
play that move right I've got the the
maroy bind designed to stop it and once
you get D5 the dream I mean I feel like
once you get D5 you've gotten rid of of
your big big weakness on D6 notice how
D5 is not a big Outpost anymore and in
fact black can start playing for a
little bit white will be the one who
will start fighting trying to get that
draw in the bailout in as quickly as
possible it will probably be a draw mvl
versus Ray Robson let's go to our
tournament leader and see how uh Ray Ray
is doing he's being tested with the
black pieces when we left it we left it
with Knight D5 and then the question is
would Ray take up the gauntlet with E4
he did and after Knight H4 castles A3
Bishop C5 Bishop G2 Peter jump in
whenever the players get out of their
let's say into novel uh ground I think
uh the the most famous game reaching
this particular position the one you
just had on your screen after castles
rookie 8 uh hikaro Nakamura won a very
uh famous game against vishan and in the
Moscow candidates uh here I think he
played it to E3 in this position if I
remember correctly uh and then VY played
it a bit imprecisely and was kind of
blown out of the water by some
sacrificial play by hikaro D3 is a much
more conservative option it makes sure
that we never blund G never blunder that
Knight on H4 by G7 but with G7 G5
because now that Bishop on C1 controls
that square but it gives black a very
easy way out to develop his pieces so
this is what happened and this is the
current position you would assume white
recaptures with the pawn because you
normally want to let's do it at least
have that uh structural Advantage a
little bit of an advantage on the queen
side with a backward Pawn on C7 perhaps
being a target of some pressure later in
the game but black has very decent piece
Activity The Pawn on E2 as you can see
had to be somewhat awkwardly defended by
the move Rook A2 I don't think this is
bad for black at all I think this is
perfectly perfectly fine you can play A7
A5 for instance ask the question about
the side structure if you want to play
B5 I would very much like to win another
Tempo by playing Queen D7 and then think
about playing Bishop H3 trade away the
bishop on G2 okay I think this is fine
for black uh I think Ray has absolutely
no reason to be unhappy with the results
of the opening here okay well uh an
experiment by by NBL didn't bring him
the desired Advantage Tanya and
sometimes it does sometimes it doesn't
but the one experiment that genius
you're a genius and I think the one
player who's happy with his experiment
could probably be Wesley last we left
that game we were a bit critical about
the decision to jump with the Knight to
D4 and allow Yan Bishi to get the
position that he wants but the way the
game has progressed and if we just catch
up let's do an action replay and we left
it here uh B4 was played here and as
we'll see the game progressed uh Wesley
managed to get the queen to a nice spot
on C4 also opened up the a line
eventually after a trade on B4 The Rook
land Ed up on A8 black has the bishop
pair and eventually I really liked what
happened here when white targeted
challenged the aine a very instructive
uh moment after Rook A1 where black says
yes you want to trade but you're going
to trade on my terms you'll trade on the
Square that I want to and Rook A4 I
think is a really nice move here if you
get the pass Pond uh that's what you're
talking about trading on your terms
exactly and white can't really avoid
that because black plans to double up
and put enough pressure on the a line uh
overloading that Queen on B2 which not
only has to defend the Rook on A1 but
also the pawn on B4 which forces white
to take a decision and if you trade on
Black's STM black is awarded with a
potentially dangerous pass Pawn on A4 I
don't know how good this is but it feels
like Wesley has created chances it does
and again the two Bishops uh Peter Jump
Right In on this I just want to agree
with everything that has been said it's
a very nice sequence I honestly it's a
good day it's a good
my eyes to my eyes and this is this is a
structural decision which I think people
will disagree but uh you're supposed to
take on F5 I think EF5 is just better I
think you have to weirdly giving
yourself this passer in the center it
just kills off your own pieces because
if we take on F5 next move we will put
the bishop on G3 we will put a rook a
rook on the E5 perhaps he was maybe
slightly worried about allowing
something like Rook E8 Rook D1 Rook E3
but if you're worried about that even
though as you can see the engine isn't
worried because it says we can drive it
away but if you are worried about that
you can start with Rook D1 I'm pretty
sure it's not going to it's not going to
hurt you very much right uh so I was a
bit surprised by E5 and also I was quite
surprised by just how willing uh Yan was
just to take on A4 at the first
opportunity because I think the engine
suggests you can you can try playing
with the idea of E5 V6 because we can
even do it
immediately the point being if it gets
picked up we take on D4 and we are very
happy with this trade I think think
frees up our position quite quite
dramatically right so he could have
tried perhaps not giving black such an
easy ride here and the position they
have now which I think is this position
right uh all of this excuse me I should
all of this has been played it's not
going to be easy for Wesley to win
because there is still the issue of the
bishop on B6 not really doing very much
uh and white has blockaded the pawn on
A4 quite quite sufficiently uh so the
way to win would be I would suspect
eventually maybe going for some kind of
G5 G4 break trying to make the bishop on
C6 into a much stronger piece by
removing
the that didn't that didn't
happen your
electromagnetic energy just Knight C5
that's a bailout move if you ask me he's
trying to make make this into some kind
of an opposite color Bishop game right
also noticeable that he is allowing
Queen F5 check and Bishop G which looks
scary but probably isn't because the
Rook on A3 also does a very good job
covering the third covering the third
and not allowing any any sacrifices so
Yan is clearly fighting for a draw here
maybe he will achieve it but I think his
play starting from this point onwards is
a little bit too compliant yes I think
he could have he could have asked more
questions in the immortal words of James
Harley McCormack uh seems to me like
white is seizing the defensive and not
just in uh this game well here white is
on the defense but another game where it
looks like white is in driver's seat and
I want to draw your attention to that
one is uh Fab's position let's take a
look a lot of decisions to be made right
now with the last few moves that we are
seeing and perhaps we can do a quick
action replay between a Fabiano and a
SAM savian it wasn't that much Tanya uh
we left it here and we were looking at
Queen G4 Knight G2 and queen F3 was uh
Fab's choice
and Sam felt like if he doesn't liberate
this bishop shortly he may never get an
opportunity My ATT it's not always about
trying to defend your piece offense can
also be a form of defense and here we
see D5 you're pointing out the bishop
opens up black is also eyeing the bishop
pair that white has right now uh so the
C4 Bishop is hanging and Fabby has
snapped up the Knight on D4 now the
question is what happens after Rook
takes E4 right I think it has to be
played and it has to be very precisely
calculated because opening up the eile
uh you win a pawn because you will
eventually pick up that Bishop on C4 but
uh after let's say queen F3 if you sort
of naively take on C4 F4 immedi C4
immediately you might be in in quite a
lot of trouble after Rook E7 you still
have Rook F4 so perhaps you don't resign
but three is that the move here H Queen
E3 I'm not sure there's Bishop D6 so at
least at the very least you will lose
the pawn on B7 and maybe there is even
more trouble coming your way but I
briefly uh looked at what the machine is
suggesting and the machine says it's
very clever for black to start by
chasing the queen away from the F3
Square so that once you eventually take
on C4 F7 will not be hanging after Rook
E7 so that wins you some time and after
Queen E2 you actually continue chasing
it around and force force you white to
put it on a square which is not as good
perhaps D3 but even this position I
would take white in yeah because Bishop
D6 is coming one day or another uh
eventually you will have to
include those pieces in the game and
that probably costs you the B7 Pawn a
lot of pieces come off though and I
wouldn't be surprised if the machine
actually holds this position because uh
it's it's a dangerous passer but
material is equal right black has solved
sort of the first wave of problems and
you can start playing something like
Queen E5 or queen C5 attack the pawn on
C3 but we'd all pick white in this
position right that passer on B6 I just
want to point out that on the topic of
machines being very good at chess uh we
only really looked at Queen F3 Queen G4
and then at some point I clicked this
magic button and the button says the
best move in the position is G3 with the
intention I assume in this position of
uh winning the Knight sacrificing
something I I actually I didn't check I
was I got slightly stuck here because
yes we've forked the rook and the and
the Knight here but with Rook takes
C4 black seemingly escapes and my first
look at this position was we are down a
bunch of material I have a suspicion the
point is we play queen2 here and and
then we just give this check and that's
and then in this end game we just
pointed those two pieces and say those
aren't ever making a move exactly but I
would need to check with the engine to
see to see if I'm correct or not let's
actually do that no you're slightly
worse Peter I why I'll give you credit
okay the takes have seven apparently
wins on the SP I don't know
I don't you can't take with the Knight
because the Rook on e4 is hanging that
one is easy that one is easy but the
question is why can't we take with the
King now we take the Knight and queen H5
now we do now we do this and then we
include the intermediate check and then
we go Rook takes C1 and then once again
we point to the other side of the board
and say we have three pieces in play and
you sir only have one one and it's your
king so so G3 G3 was very strong there
for Fabi but he played a move
opportunity I think play a move that
most of us would have played I think
que3 is just so logical and it just begs
to be played and Rook E4 is that on he
has played Rook E4 and Rook takes C4
naively as you suggested there's there's
also G G6 included so there was some
chasing it was a queen F5 perhaps yeah
okay just a second Let me refresh my
board to uh confirm that but yes he did
play Queen F5 similar idea please
recapture the bishop so that Rook e s um
and maybe even well no Rook D7 you still
have Rook F4 he did after uh oop excuse
me this he did play G6 I wanted to say
uh G6 Queen F3 and he didn't play Rook
F4 as suggested he played take C4 but
shockingly G6 looks like a weakening
move but the engine actually suggests
it's better for black to have it I think
because if we continue the variation
from here before Rook E7 yeah Rook E7
black can play Rook F4 okay and after
Queen D3 yeah the fact that there is now
a G7 G7 Square for the King which wasn't
available before allows black apparently
to take Queen takes
B6
whoa all allow Rook E8 check which would
have been made right without the
inclusion of G7 G6 and now King G7 F2 is
hanging you're still would be I think
very very worried with black because
there's this seemingly Eternal pin on
the back r
right but the engine weirdly suggest
this is fine yeah maybe it is because
you've also got these ideas of Rook E4
trying to trade off the Rooks get some
pressure off and always watch out for
threats of Bishop H2 check at some
moment so you can't really maintain your
Rook on the last rank right and it's
really interesting how this move G6 has
changed so much in the position giving
black these additional opportunities uh
and we see Fabby there on our screens uh
he's thinking he's uh under 9 minutes on
the clock a little ahead and he goes in
he goes in with the Rook Rook E7 played
so Rook to F4 is the move that we're
expecting Blitz out immediately by Sam
Rook
F4 and uh okay I kind of like the B6
Pawn I mean queen E3 is it Rook
e is it Rook E4 Rook E4 I think is the
way to go here yeah you you can't allow
rookie H check and if you can lose the
pawn on D5 instead of the Pawn on B7 I
think you take that every day any day of
the week I'm just a little curious cuz
I'm not exactly sure how you're still
untangling uh we can play Bishop D6
because we have Bishop H2 check right oh
that's that's what it hinges on I think
that's nasty of course I was setting you
up for this terrible trap where I was
going to go Rook to
E8 and this looks like the players are
about to make a repetition just in time
to catch it and there we have hand
repetition yes
result of the day Anish giri Jeffrey
Jang ends in a draw a relatively
peaceful game yeah uh I think both
players have nothing to complain and to
be pleased with the start of the day
yeah but somehow in addition to Theory
too Queen A5 sh and queen d8 interesting
opening a nice uh debut I want to say
for uh black Peter yeah I think it's a
good start of the day for for for
Jeffrey who's had a bit of an
nondescript event so far and black
against renowned theoretician uh such as
Anish in anish's own opening so to speak
is is a very good result back there six
draws for Anish so far and well he won
the one one win against one wi and six
draws and exchange down he's had winning
positions let's let's an Nish he just
didn't capitalize he only capitalized
when he was in a bad position in a bad
position that's the secret that's the
secret sauce for's when I wanted to go
to our tournament leader Ray Robson
against mvl um when we left it we
thought that Ray had pretty much gotten
a balanced position A5 B5 on the board
A4 an an indication that uh Ray is a
little bit more ambitious he's thinking
maybe Rook A5 maybe I can artificially
isolate it the pawn on B5 uh King H1 a
Prelude you want to maybe play F4 maybe
you don't want to play F4 but in any
case you need to give yourself the
option option it's in the air now yes
precisely so Queen
D7 gift me the pawn on B5 not so fast
Rook B2 Rook A5 now it comes F4 and
where we go Queen to D3 this I don't
think I'm going to be trapping the
bishop anytime soon but okay just
something to ensure that it doesn't get
trapped Ray Play Bishop H3 and uh bring
it give us your take on this uh position
Peter of our tournament leader I I can
see the engine suggesting this is
completely equal my question is the very
logical continuation from here seems to
be take take a massive massive trades on
e4 I will eventually be able to do that
and then the capture on B5 and at first
I thought there is just a very easy
Perpetual with the with the recapture on
B5 and queen6 check but after King f8 I
will be able to play Queen E8 if you
play Queen C8 check and I don't see an
immediate draw for white here it might
still be salvageable but I'm not so sure
this is this is a good choice yeah so
what I'm wondering is maybe we're
supposed to play something like Rook E2
here but that also doesn't look that
also doesn't look very clear oh Queen F5
drops The Rook maybe this maybe this is
but then Queen F7 maybe yeah give me the
pawn on D five this apparently is a draw
because white can play Queen E6 none of
this is obvious at all because I would
suggest that in Practical terms if I
didn't know this was a draw I would
think I might be losing just just
straight up black yeah yeah exactly
because black as a pawn up and the the E
Pawn will be very safely block as you
can see the evolution instantly goes
from 0 Z to minus 2 and a half so E7 is
a DI so the reason it's equel I suspect
is we play Bishop B2 and we will be
taking Bishop takes G7 check next move
mhm so that restores the material
balance because let's imagine like Rook
B3 we will take on
G7 uh and now the the material balance
is restored and we can also start
pushing our own our oops that's not what
I in yeah H4 with ideas of course we
have Rook E3 I mean that's actually
Ultra sharp and the and the Triple O's
is completely
misleading
uh
they go to almost for rayson and queen
takes G6 a little less than 10 minutes
from Max hasn't been played Queen takes
G6 was chosen instead Rook takes D5 D5
yeah Ray continuing to choose the most
principled options and playing really
well because I think you'd be tempted to
think Rook e 2 is winning because how
are you stopping Rook f8 Rook E8 check
but there is Rook
F5 switching switching to defense just
in time
and all these that we're pointing out it
looks like R Robson has a real chance to
actually try and trick Maxim vasher lra
in a position where he can be a little
ambitious but what I'm scared about is
his clock situation right now 30 seconds
yeah 33 seconds against 9 minutes in a
position where you will
still still have to play extremely
precisely exactly and still a very very
sharp position for for me I'm looking at
a a tactic here please fall for it I
want to play the move Bishop to B2 M so
I really desperately want you to defend
the pawn on G7 and now to
introduce nicely done yeah a knockout
shot Bishop takes G7 Rook takes G7 Rook
E8 and I do win your queen for rook and
Bishop so how is Ray well asked and
answered Queen C6 check best move in the
position by the way H3 and he will go
back I suspect creating a lot of
discovered check threats you mean queen
D7
I'm going back and that's really nice
because if you give a check on the back
rank black Retreats with a rook with a
counter check on white King on H3 it's
like those commercials they make uh on
the board Queen D7 how is Rey Robson so
precise play how many times in this
tournament we've seen him play on
seconds and play the absolute best moves
I don't know how he does it at Tanya
you're really wow uh but here I've got
to ask the question why is G4 not
winning yeah exactly why is G4 not
winning I'm so far a bit confused
apparently it loses because after Rook
F4 Bishop takes G7 a bishop takes G7
isn't made we can just take on G7 and we
still have Rook a fade there yes in this
case Bishop takes G7 The Rook is no is
not in the way Queen takes G7 as you
said Peter Rook E8 check rook f8 and
everything holds together so the way for
for maxim to continue here playing for a
win would be to go forward with the King
maybe just a play King H3 H4 wow but I
have to say that G4 can be a very
tempting option here
because you're looking at all these
ideas of Bishop takes pawn and it takes
a lot of class to realize that Bishop
takes Pawn is actually not Checkmate
exactly so of course Maxim and they've
repeated it he is repeating and this is
the second time King G2 would be a draw
on the spot but King H4 good General
leads his Army to victory is he going to
do it yes so that's the big question
does Maxim want to play for a win in
this position but Peter if you do play
King H4 what's the
EV zeros zeros because well you have to
drop back to f8 now because now Bishop
takes G7 hanging is a threat genuine
white in response doesn't have an
immediate threat but you can improve
another one of your pieces by uh playing
Rook E6 with idea of F5 it looks
incredibly threatening but the engine is
very sine about it yeah C6 apparently is
fine even a very slow move like Bishop 6
B6 C5 is somehow fine I would not be uh
you know very eager to play this on 10
seconds with black I I would very that
would be the thing that tempts Maxim to
continue the game with King H1 but this
one is over Fabiano Karana Sam savan
ends in a peaceful result and the big
question will Maxim and the tournament
leader and the same way uh this is the
moment he hasn't decided yet when your
opponent's playing on seconds it's so
tempting to continue with King H4 but
King H4 on its own is such a brave move
to play the Queens on the board the
Rooks on the board and here you are
Marching up with the King well I'll
leave it to the historians to talk about
my courageous uh play but I do oh he
doesn't do it aw and and that's it he
claims Robson claims he's going Queen C6
handshakes yes uh I'm just stunned that
and look at that I think they're
analyzing the exact line that we're
talking about King H4 sitting on the
board right now such a complicated
position with the Rook stepping onto E8
yeah and mvl making the universal hand
gesture for I have no idea what's going
on there chose not to do it let's jump
to two of our remaining games we've got
nepo and Wesley so
uh let me just interrupt myself because
is though yeah is Wesley's King not just
like in terrible duress and the reason
you're pausing is because at first you
know itce Black's Pawn on A2 Wesley has
this Pawn which is one step away White's
got this King on H4 we were talking
about Kings on H4 well on this game it's
happened uh that King can't be saved but
again opposite color bishop and it is
all about the attack notice how Black's
Bishop the light Square Bishop can't get
to White's King but on the other hand
the queen and Bishop that Yan have can
create a meeting net around the E7
Square absolutely and the big question
is who's getting to who's King first I
think Yan is getting to uh wesle game
I'm just looking at Queen E6 check which
he has just played king d8 queen D6
check go to C8 yes don't go to C8 that
will walk into miden one you've got to
go back now I can consider the move
Bishop
F6 and uh again I'm looking at mating
ideas on the dark squares the King on H4
is perfectly placed wow perfectly placed
and Bishop F6 the move you want to make
with black is Queen to E2 stop that mate
but notice how the queen also needs to
defend the bishop on C6 exactly so
Bishop F6 as you were just pointing out
it's a dual problem
you want to defend the mate shocking
black can actually go King F7 King G8
and this is not mate I want to attract a
view attention also to to the clock
moment to the clocks Yan has 11 minutes
against a minute for Wesley 11 to one
are we surprised about Yan having 11
minutes no uh but I that's Yan doing Yan
things yeah but you're you you just said
King F7 king7 King G8 apparently holds
wow amazing is that the only way to hold
the position it might be I think because
checks achieve achieve nothing at all
starting with queen of to check only
improves White's position because you
will get your king over to H6 where it's
completely safe and then black will
actually be in a even more of a mating
net because you have three pieces
attacking the
king yeah fantastic fantastic play by
Wesley finding the absolute best play
here we saw it it he was a Houdini
escaping against fuia oh my God that
King on F5 was it wow wow wow that was
just remarkable Queen E7 check King G8
and it's sort of like you you you you
cast your net Peter but the king is not
yeah given given some more time the the
engine is now saying this is also pretty
bad but you have to start making quiet
check no you just make Quiet Moves Here
It Go quiet move it goes Bishop C3 for
reasons
unexplained Bishop C3 tell me why I'm
doing Bishop C3 a quiet I can not I
refuse so if I do a quiet move just help
me out here now Queen E8 probably is
mate right you can't allow queen queen
E8 and so there is an idea okay and he
he gives a check the most natural
looking move on the board it's such a
human uh move to go Queen E6 King comes
back refresh yeah refresh my board for a
moment so the idea once again is after
Queen E7 check King G8 quiet move and
say it's your turn Mister what are you
going to do I have a suspicion it's
basically black maybe has every single
piece on the best POS Square okay and
passing the move over to to Wesley makes
him make very very uncomfortable choices
here pet I have a question now in these
positions you know the general feeling
is if the Queens are off the board it
should be a draw but can in some
positions with that Bishop on C3 is
Queen G5 and actually threatening to go
into an opposite color Bishop where you
either end up winning the H5 Pawn or the
F5 pawn and maybe we can just quickly
show that y so with Queen E7 King G8 the
point I'm trying to make is it's
obviously more tempting to keep the
Queens on the board but does black need
to be careful about Queen G5 trades and
one of the pawns falling off it will
have to be a very very specific
situation because I think after the
queen trade black probably will have
enough Tempe to protect at least one of
those two so and if you only lose one of
the F5 H5 pair you probably the you hold
yeah yeah Bishops of opposite color uh
so needs to keep the Queens on the
board but I think it's PL the the
problem is we can maybe play for mate
successfully Queen E6 check Queen takes
F5
is on the agenda by the way Queen takes
F5 immediately let me just uh Let me
refresh my board to get the current
position this is what he played yeah and
actually why not I I'm a pawn Grabber
you're a pawn Grabber you love it and
you're also threatening some checks with
the bishop the queen and the King line I
am I mean there's a discovery and queen
came he played Bishop to e Play Bishop
which I which I don't really like I
think the engine was suggesting Quin D5
was required required and it was
seemingly holding on once again the
depth may may need to be increased for a
conclusive uh answer there this
apparently is now back to being very
very bad for black even though I I
hesitate to even tell you what the first
line is I I would start with the
discovered check Bishop D4 check just to
cover the F2 Square yeah and then try to
get my queen on the business square of
h8 I think it doesn't like allowing
Bishop F7 the engine but he's but he's
done Bishop D4 yeah this is a very very
very human mov it's still winning but uh
there were some very machine like
suggestions there which seemed to be
Bishop F7 the idea of retreating with
the bishop to guard the king and and now
Queen C5 check wins by force I assume
because you will actually you will be
able to you can't go to G8 yeah you will
peel the the the black king out of the
he he's done the queen C5 check because
if he had gone the other way then we
quickly check check and skew the queen
so King E8 box and again it's 11 minutes
to 1 minute still right uh should be
able to figure this out is this queen C8
Queen C8 followed by Bishop C5 followed
by Queen h8 check and eventually you win
the bishop with checks at least the
bishop Bishop you wi was B the bishop
was check is the human calculators
you're just like I can't even put the
moves AR fast enough Queen h8 check
Bishop C5 is easy but is queen queen h8
most precise check will he find this one
I think it's fine cuz King G6 I think
you lose to Bishop D4 maybe even Bishop
D4 or que5 also looks very good though
yeah but I very much like this idea of
making a quiet move here and saying okay
please make a move in response I don't
want to I will refuse and queen G7 is a
big threat so he gives the first right
check Queen C8 on the board yes he does
Bishop C5 to follow King Yan is going to
find this oh yes I think so and this
will make him feel a lot more cheerful
about the tournament because it really
has been a a very disappointing first
couple of days for but the nightmare
continues for you bestly done
exactly exactly Bishop C5 is it on the
board or Yan has slowed down that's our
guess and the fact that he has slow down
is actually a very good sign I think in
general him not blitzing moves out in
this position uh shows that he he knows
he's very close and he knows he doesn't
want to spoil it and this is the moment
Queen H and he plays it instantly yes
this one he had worked
out so you have to you have to run
towards the center not to get mated and
then just to show our viewers King E6 we
give a check from E5 a check from D6
first I think is more precise a king F5
Play I'm I suspect this is just mate now
after King F5 Queen
E5 yeah Queen E5 and now Bishop D4
apparently is like mate in eight my
screen says he's reaching out for the
bishop and he plays it Peter knows Yan
Bishop D4 ideas of F5 G7 and look at
that King on H4 just chilling no checks
available no checks the safest King on
the board and it's handshakes and well
done because we thought that Wesley
actually had the upper hand in this one
we have one remaining game what's going
on uh between Ali Raza and Liam uh was a
pretty sharp night end game but it no
longer is all that sharp I would say I
think this this has to be very very
level white with with the outside passer
on the H file probably has the you know
the famous theoretical Moral Moral
Advantage right the the the fabled moral
Advantage but it should be a draw yeah
it should and I very much like the
engine suggestion of playing 96 C8 here
just to go try to remove the entire
Queen side right and I think it's really
interesting what you said about this
outside Bast Pawn for the newer chess
audience because in a King Pawn ending
imagine if the knights are off the board
and you have a Pawn on a flank the
further away it's from the center the
more of a strength it is because it
forces your opponent's king towards the
flank while your own King can go ahead
in the center and grab the pawns closer
exactly and Knight endings are very
close to King Pawn endings so having a
having an outside parel which in this
case is the H Pawn gives white that
slight Edge but you're saying it's not
going to be enough because black has a
lot of activity firstly on the queen
side already and look at that King on F5
a very active King and
one of the Anor one of the problems that
white has is maybe if this Pawn were for
example on A2 the fact that it's on A4
black can liquidate the queen Side by
forcing Knight C8 to B6 and if I'm
forced to take well who has the outside
passer after all and that's why the
engine is actually going Triple O's by
the way the move night C8 isn't
intuitively obvious you're you're you're
you're kind of thinking C5 C4 you're
you're still which could still hold but
it's maybe slightly less uh slightly
less clean but finding backward moves in
end games is is
Trick are so difficult retreating Nights
night moves especially are more
difficult yeah so H2 H3 tries to say
also kind of hoping to tip the balance
in my favor if I can get I see the King
by the way as being beautifully placed
on F5 if I can get your king to release
it and go somewhere uh I would be very
happy by the way we Knight B7 as a
retreating move not simar idea he wants
to go to C5 and very quickly came Knight
F3 with the idea of Knight D4 check this
is a very safe choice but Knight E4
arguably was maybe the slightly more
challenging one because what alza will
get now is a position where he will have
uh F andh against F basically the entire
Queen side will disappear very in very
very short order and we just will have
an extra Pawn on the king side but two
pawns against one a night ending two
against one generally is a very
comfortable but you were about to
suggest Knight E4 as a way of keeping
trying to dominate that Knight on B7
yeah that was why maybe Knight C8 was
more accurate Knight C8 to B6 the move
Knight B7 actually invited Knight E4
stopping Knight C5 this did not happen
Ali Raza did play Knight F3 and we are
now up to date with the players and C6
C5 I actually thought he was going to go
Knight C5 I was pretty sure he was going
to go Knight C5 but he's being he's
being greedy and I quite like this uh
this kind of greed why why subject
yourself to suffering in a slightly
worse when you can play position with
equal material I'm seeing the Knight as
being a bit dominated though Peter are
we sure this is equal King F5 and then
C4 King F and then start offloading
material King F3 played yeah but now you
can play C4 I think pretty safely uh and
give yourself the C5 Square for the
night and yeah I I don't really see how
you lose this with play and Liam's
reaching for the SE pwn by the way is
time time clocks a factor in this one
Tanya it's uh I think it's very close
it's a 30- second Advantage for Liam and
it's a position where the ideas are very
clear so I don't believe the clock will
be the biggest Factor here uh the moves
are not that difficult it's not that
complex and also it feels like only
moves to be played to really try so C4
King E3 you can jump in with your knight
to C5 and white will start attacking
Black's Pawns in return you can you can
go Knight D6 check and the the gra C4
and attack A5 and then we're going to
get that ending that you uh talked about
h and f Pawn versus F6 pawn two versus
one and they've cleaned up the queen
side yeah it's possible to lose this but
you have to you have to commit it's some
very very egregious if the KN are traed
that's lost if you're able to get in a
check in most cases probably
99.9% yeah any Forks where the knights
are traded uh definitely winning for
white uh Black's idea is very very clear
uh he would just love to sacrifice the
Knight for the two
pawns but it's really it's really
important that the two pawns are
separated so it might not be that easy
to sacrifice the Knight for both pawns
exactly and and uh if one pawn and also
there's no Pawn trade that's very
obvious because what black really wants
to do is get rid of one set of Pawns and
then sacrifice the Knight for the
remaining Pond by the way King H5 is a
nice move very much so to try to Cozy up
to this H3 Pawn if we imagine White's
King on G uh pardon me I I wanted to put
it white in a position where he had to
defend the H Pawn and at double duty you
get to play Knight takes F4 draw the
king away and then that's a nice tactic
and May you can show that yes we can
play some helpful moves like we'll just
play some uh moves for the moment and
we'll get a situation where we get this
and this is how you sacrifice how you
sacrifice the Knight for the two uh
pawns and of course as you see our score
of the two players we see why this game
is so critical for fua a victory uh
would allow him to catapult uh Lea frog
if you will over Liam uh with a win but
only a win with a draw Liam keeps a lead
over fuja let me just refresh my board
as we only have one decisive result thus
far one decisive result it was Yan pishi
winning against Wesley s so for Wesley
it's really not been a a good event and
he's got to get himself going in the
blitz that's his big hope now but for
Yan a crucial win to try to get the
tempo going and we see the F5 Pawn will
fall now and it without sacrifice and
players will make a draw yeah we saw
that with the players there kind of an
agreement there that this is now ending
in a draw and we see there the king will
March forward it will be a king versus
King and it was
um impressive impressive save by Liam
again Liam's coming into this event as
the Wild Card he's going up against the
tournament grandchester champion of
2022 uh Ali Raza and black pieces that
was a big test and he answered
superbly fantastic uh round for uh Liam
I want to say I think he should be
satisfied with this he defended the
slightly unpleasant position very very
carefully and didn't really look like he
was in trouble at any particular point
and starting with a draw with BL against
the is a very sound start of the day
right and let's take a look at the
standings uh Tanya after uh round seven
in the history books absolutely yes
going into the penultimate round of the
rapid we've got Ray Robson the wild card
if you're a supporter of the underdog
you should be feeling very proud in this
tournament with heavy weights playing it
is Ray Robson with nine points just two
games remaining Maxim VRA gam tied for
second position Ali Resa fuja fabii and
yan yan has sneaked his way up the
leaderboard little bit there yeah
victory yeah and Wesley struggling we're
coming we've come to that point in the
show where we like to talk about what's
happening with our friends at Q Boutique
and they have this it's sports hat St
Louis chess club sports hat stay sporty
in the sun wait a minute are we going to
fall winter never mind stay sporty in
the sun with these classic baseball caps
100% polyester with adjustable velcro
strap across the back available in
multiple collar and one size fits most
notice they didn't say all fits most
represent the St Louis CH Club in style
available at couti stl.com and as we go
on break Anastasia caught up with Yan
and had a nice little interview hope you
enjoy it I'll see you on the other side
of the
[Music]
break Yan welcome to St Louis welcome to
Grand tour it's it's great to see you
here again how did you feel when you
came back here after more than one year
and what was your initial reaction when
you came to the hotel to the club uh
well it's good to see the club finally
renovated I think uh it took took a
while so last year it was everything was
like a little bit of mess so another
entrance another drawer another another
room another everything uh okay this
here it looks like uh the job done or or
maybe I I haven't been to you know
everywhere just here so for now but I
hope so uh and uh yeah it's finally it's
finally chance to see uh the city you
know
and uh just not um not you know in the
midsummer when it's like a little bit
too hot but in November so it's um you
know it's still warm enough but uh you
know I expect I expected to to get a
little bit Frosty uh closer to the end
of the tournament yeah like uh end of
November but for now yeah it's um it's
very fine so finally it's uh no heat but
just some normal average average
temperature yeah yeah that's true and uh
speaking about your GCT situation you
played in the tournaments in Romania
then in Croatia so where are you now and
where do you want to get you tell me I
you know I never that's maybe that's
maybe the problem with my overall result
but you know I never check the standings
of the gcd tour I know other guys do and
they play for for result but I just play
you know for no no let's say not for fun
but yeah for for some experience for
some excitement but uh yeah I think I'm
doing not that bad uh you know if not a
tournament in Bucharest I would be doing
like nice I think because it was like
some second place in Croatia but uh yeah
well
where where do you want to get let's say
the second part well I I want to win but
you know it's I always want to win but
what's I I don't think it depends only
on me sometimes it doesn't but last year
actually you came very close you were
second and you had chances yeah yeah
thank you for thank you for reminding
that's
very uh you know very hard forming very
touching of you yes of course I mean
sorry to to remind you about this it was
a really special event in any case and
which singfield cup which GCT event was
the most memorable for you I guess uh I
guess London
2017 uh then um uh you know I had no
hopes for for anything but then suddenly
okay i w three in a row and yeah if only
if only Mickey Adams would accept a
freeold repetition at some point against
Fabby it would be uh would be a very
fine event to to win but then okay it
came to tip breaks and then okay Fabby
uh surprisingly after 6 hours games 6our
game was more fresh than me uh he was
watching this six hour
game yeah but anyway any that was like
um a good EV end but uh yeah normally I
I expect you know every next event to be
better yeah yeah maybe let's see what
happens this year but let's speak a
little bit about something else the
candidates tournament because everybody
is talking about it you know that GC
event is also part of this F circuit and
few players are still fighting for the
spot so but they been fighting for the
spot so I don't care that you're not yes
I know you're there already but I think
you you would keep an eye on the others
and in general what do you think about
the field already I mean we know some
names and whom do you prefer to see in
the candidates tournament from those who
are playing here it's Wesley Anish and I
think Al are still fighting I don't know
it's uh I guess any any of this three is
like quite formidable opponent so
it's uh you never know until until the
tournament starts who's like in a good
shape who is like uh is not so well
prepared yet so we'll see
but for the C current situation I think
uh Anish and uh Anish is on the second
place have slightly better chances yeah
than Wesley um Wesley is on the thir
place oh yeah Wesley but Wesley is still
in in the competition yeah and you know
when the tournament is important he
always you know tries to show his best
so okay let's see let's grab some
popcorn for sure but you're still
playing here and you will play in the
candidates you won two previous ones and
are you ready to repeat the
success what are you doing for it
absolutely I don't
mind uh but that's you know it's once
again it depends on
manufacturers yeah so first of all um
who's playing when is the you know when
is the tournament where is the
tournament so it's uh will I make it to
Canada yeah like getting my Visa or not
so also also quite um quite a question
yeah to be honest so yeah you know let's
see but um I guess uh you playing a
couple of match just leaves you with
some nice amount of
preparation uh but um anyway anyway even
having like this uh you know big lug ISS
you still have to you know to work and
to prepare so see always something to
prepare for yeah yeah yeah and I wish
you to play well in the tournament so
the best of luck for you thank you for
the interview thank you the 2023 Grand
chess tour reaches its epic conclusion
with its fifth world class event the
2023 sinkfield cup it's back to
classical chess with Front Runners
settling in for the final push to the
Finish Line however two of America's
Finest stand in their way joining the
frey as wild cards who will try to cash
in on the opportunity while making
making things as difficult as possible
for hopeful tour players who can win the
illustrious cup and will it be enough
for them to emerge as the 2023 Grand
chess tour Champion follow the St Louis
chess club's twitch and YouTube channels
to tune in to live coverage of the 2023
sinkfield cup November 21st to December
1st to find
out hello I'm women's grandmas viim
janova I will be creating content for
grest store follow us on social media
and catch more behind the scenes
content the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Louis chess club.org to
claim your membership today the World
Chess Hall of Fame located in the heart
of St Louis's historic Central West End
want to know why chess has intrigued
people around the world for nearly 1,500
years stop by and learn about the impact
of Chess from our three floors
showcasing the art culture and history
of the game the World Chess Hall of Fame
has something for everyone to enjoy for
more information on current exhibits
please visit worldes h.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chest sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy the St Louis
chess club Scholastic program brings the
educational value of Chess to kids and
schools across the St Louis area active
in over 100 schools throughout the St
Louis city and county the St Louis chess
club has been able to reach over 85,000
students in both in school and after
school programs we view chess as a
valuable educational tool SCH learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
education hello I'm women's Grand Master
R to janova I will take you behind the
scenes of the grand chest tour follow us
on social media and don't miss out on
players interviews and more content from
the playing
Hall the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States and is among the best in the
world thanks to co-founders Dr jeie
Karen sinkfield and Rex sinkfield the St
Louis chess club is a nonprofit
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game team of Chess
we also promote Chess at the highest
levels hosting all levels of the US
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sinkfield cup
Ken cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over
2,000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures we weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit St Louis chess club.org
to claim your membership
[Music]
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floor showcasing the art
culture and history of the game
landmarked by the world's largest chest
piece sitting outside our front door the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy including various
exhibitions monthly concerts and much
more whether you are a beginner or a
professional there is something for
everyone to learn here at the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy free admission
to our rotating exhibitions and our
Galleries and sign up for chess events
familyfriendly programming and art
classes and don't forget to stop by our
award-winning gift shop Q Boutique and
Shop a wide selection of Chess related
merchandise for more information on
current exhibits please visit worldes
h.org
hello and welcome back everyone as we're
about to kick off round eight the
penultimate round of the St Louis rapid
and it's been quite a already with just
two games remaining it's fire on the
board what we're expecting let's take a
look at the standings and this is where
we are going into round eight few would
have predicted this at the start of the
tournament Ray Robson after round seven
leading in this monstrous field with
nine points he's feeling really good and
he's playing really good he just drew
against MV with the black pieces NBL
Anish G Liam Lee all in a tie for second
and as you mentioned Yan
just kind of sneaking up there he hasn't
uh uh done that great but he's feeling
better pairings for this round eight
Tanya with just two games remaining the
players have to bring in all their
energy on the board and it is Juicy
matchups all around starting with Anish
giri taking on Fabiana Karana tournament
leader Ray Robson will play Yan pomi we
just spoke about has been finding his
rhythm and form the last couple of games
Liam Le faces Maxim vasia lra Jeffrey
Jang against a struggling so Wesley and
Sam Sean plays ala fua Liam versus mvl
two players tied for second that will be
a very interesting uh Marquee matchup
indeed and why are these rapid results
so important because in our history uh
we looked it up just to confirm it most
often the player who wins the rapid
Tanya wins it all ended up winning the
entire rapid and Blitz and this is the
fourth stop of the grand Chester uh Ray
Robson looking good to get in that
Victory and there we have it our past
winners Magnus Carlson won the rapid won
the blitz Leon aronian won the rapid won
the blitz Hikaru Nakamura in 2018 winner
of both events it was Magnus Carlson
again in 2019 and 2019 yes Kava and
Maxim vasher lra the Paris rapid and
bits that said 2023 we have been seeing
a switch up around that W the first look
at this you still go on we still go on
and we see the tradition does continue
was Tata played in where was Tata played
Tata steel 2019 was in India I know that
but where was it in kakata kakata it was
in Kolkata and Magnus Carlson once again
winning 2019 it was Leon arunan who won
the St Louis rapid and Blitz and as we
see so many times in the history of
Grand Chester a player winning the rapid
goes on to win the blitz if Ray Robson
finishes the task ahead of him and goes
on to repeat tradition that would be
historical in the Chess World no
question about it wow that would be
amazing Peter you were so enthusiastic
about what we missed yesterday please
line that was suggested by by the
machine as always but we spoke at length
about this game this was a very dramatic
game in round five between Anish giri on
the white side against uh Le liim uh the
game that white didn't miss a win here
but there's a very very beautiful uh
Forest win available to Anish here
starting with this move Rook
A3 and I want to ask you guys why can't
we take this Rook well Knight F6 Knight
F6 I have this incredibly beautiful move
Queen G3 check
oh and maybe maybe this is still winning
because if you take if you take this
loses for white maybe you still win with
Queen takes G3 but it will take ages
Break Down The Fortress you're not even
assured of the result but Knight G5
laughing Queen G3 this is just so
beautiful you give up all of your pieces
apart from that one Queen on G6 and it
delivers the final blow on the H6 square
and the big difference with what Anish
did in the game is that black in the
game defended by pinning this Knight on
this diagonal and the move Rook A3 stops
that from happening the Knight continues
being free to Rome and for instance
after Queen C1 we can and we should play
the move Knight D6 creating a threat of
Knight F7 mate and then we go G3 what
now and everything starts collapsing and
we win I just wanted to show this
variation specifically because it is it
is just such a wonderful example of
using all of your resources optimally
sometimes all you need is a queen that
is very true pet thank you life advice
as well really beautiful what is really
really nice is that desirable Knight F6
meets Queen G3 I also also wanted to
show that that is that is a very
pleasing move to make and six is the
more dting option the one that you play
instantly and a really stunning line
there Anish giri winning the missing the
win with that and the game eventually
ended in a draw okay now I got to ask
when did that occur to you where was it
just staring staring at the screen helps
a great deal
so it was actually in real time then
that I claim I claim no credit the the
the first line suggested this to me and
but it kept on telling me Rook A3 and I
was sort of ignoring it and then I
thought hang on a second why can't I
take right and then it it dawned that n
G5 I don't believe that Anish missed uh
Knight F6 Queen G3 I think Rook A3 that
on the radar is very difficult until
it's unless it's pointed out unless you
either see an evalar shoot up and you
know that there's something specific in
this position or are showing us but Rook
A3 just doesn't come to a human mind no
especially for me in this particular
case it feels like White's dominating so
a move like Rook F7 Rook F3 I don't have
to do anything complicated it's all
winning yeah but Rook A3 is sweet yes
it's a retreating move and it's a
hanging rook and it's a hanging Rook as
the players are getting ready for round
eight by the way that's something I
missed today uh in the old days before
chess engines were very strong you'd be
sitting at your dinner you'd be thinking
about the game that's adjourned or just
been played and completed and then boink
you're thunder struck because you come
up with Rook A3 you immediately look
around the dining hall and you find your
opponent and say dude you know I had you
with Rook A3 and they're like oh thank
God you didn't play that you missed
those times Peter to to a degree yeah
it's it's very disappointing that these
days you you you ex go to the ex exit
the playing call you pick up your phone
from the log box where you had to leave
it and you switch it on and it tells you
just how just how stupid you were
throughout the entire game and it's uh
it's not the most Pleasant feeling in
the world no no as the players are
getting ready for this round eight again
I just want to uh refresh everybody's uh
uh the standings uh if you don't mind as
Ray Robson is doing something just
unbelievable Wild Card Player invited at
the last moment there you see him in
clear first I mean talk about you we're
going to give you a moment in the Sun
Ray says let me take advantage of it t
this could very well be the tournament
of his life if he manages to finish at
the top he won the cck Masters early
this year against a very very strong
field so he is having a second wind in
his chess career and he's enjoying like
but right now Yana pomi might have
something to say about that it's still
two games be played firstly that and
secondly I would like to Second win how
old is he exactly he's 22 not 28 he's 28
28 still I I still will not allow it no
I think I think he is way too young for
second
wins these days they start chess as you
become a Grandmaster of 14 or 12 or some
crazy I'm age still not not allowing
that you know uh Larry Christensen once
won the kindergarten championship and
then when into a slump for like seven
years so he got a he got a third fourth
and fifth win tell no and I was going to
say the the American wild cards in this
tournament Ray Robson Jeffrey Jong Sam
savian uh all these three players were
prodigies growing up they set so many
records as youngsters becoming run
Masters at a very young age I think they
were 14 years old and uh they continue
to impress and these are the kind of
opportunities that maybe these players
don't get as much and that is what is
amazing about a tournament like that
like this where you've got the top
players in the world playing you've also
got these extremely strong talented
youngsters with a stage where they can
play against the absolute best in the
world and here we've got Ray Robson
leading the field no question and I felt
that way also during the Tata steel when
the Tata steel tournament uh went to uh
India and I saw all of those Junior
players playing in the Rapids and Blitz
and I thought oh dear India is
coming we have a a grunfeld on the board
this looks all very traditional grunfeld
expert in the house exactly but I just
wanted to say I think we've got some
chaos no it's also grunfeld we got gr
Fields all around there's there's two
Grom Fields today uh and uh it's always
nice to see the other one is Ray is
still choosing what to play and he he
ends up playing the classical the the
bishop 492 setup uh a much more quirky
version is being played in the game
between uh Le and mvl but it also could
have been uh crazier I think mvl went
for a a quieter reply to what I think is
colloquially known as an Armenian
groomfield
really it's it's so funny uh Peter I
want to I mean you've been playing
groomfield your career so you've seen um
openings come in and out of fashion
Bishop C4 Knight E2 to that was the
setup for the 50s 60s 7s and the way you
go then Knight F3 Bishop E2 became the
setup and now we're seeing uh it's very
much back back in Vogue and uh is Back
to the Future giving a lot of headaches
I think for for the grinfield players
very interesting to see what what Yan
will Bish G4 very quickly by this is the
very very old Mainline provided he goes
F3 Knight A5 he might go Bishop D7
though there is a very important choice
of
on the next move F3 will be played as we
can see on AIA he goes he goes for
Bishop D7 he doesn't go for Knight A5
that was uh played in the casparo karpov
1990 World Championship Match uh and I
think Anatoli showed that there are some
issues eventually it was worked out it
has to be you have to be very very
precise Knight A5 in this position is my
recommendation in the course but uh it
wasn't a particularly happy
recommendation because I have always
been and have have become even more lazy
as as years go by and there is a lot of
memorization involved if you want to
play uh F3 Knight A5 in this position
right I used to I used to be I used to
be the the bishop D7 main so to speak I
I played this exclusively for many many
years but I've become a bit
disillusioned with this line because I
think it gives white a number of options
to for getting a pleasant position
please share uh well the positions after
Rook C1 Rook C8 Queen D2 I I think are
not uh entirely equal but there is also
additional issues like there's a lot of
lines where you actually have to be very
careful if why just takes on C5 perhaps
not immediately here but uh there is a
lot of intricate differences between all
the versions in which white goes dc5 you
constantly have to watch for D4 D5 ideas
and as everywhere else these days the
move H4 remarkably is is always going to
be a bit of an issue at least so uh it's
playable I understand why un chose it
because I think compared with Bishop G4
Knight A5 if we if we compare the
winning chances black has in this
position and the position of the bishop
D7 I think Bishop D7 gives you a much
bigger chance of a three res game but
it's also riskier I think objectively
all right let's jump in that case to uh
the game between uh Liam and MV again
they're playing a groom Feld and these
two players are actually in a tie for
second and we've got a very different
approach by white what happened
absolutely
uh uh Liam played Knight F3 here Bishop
G7 C takes D5 Knight takes D5 and Knight
A4 and this move looks very very
outlandish I think at first glance uh
and the The Armenian grunfeld even even
more specifically the nadan grinfield
there's there's an Armenian player
called AAL nadan who uh many many years
ago discovered the idea of taking on D5
and playing Knight A4 on move five not
on move six but there are obviously a
lot of transpositions between these two
the idea of course is we want to play to
E4 and we want to do it without giving
black the option of trading on C3 which
strengthens uh our Center but also uh
black doesn't have to spend the tempo
running away with the Knight there's
lots of potential replies here uh mvel
goes for the most straightforward he
goes uh Castle Z4 KN B6 Bishop B3 and in
this position there is a lot of very
sharp line starting with Bishop G4 to
which white I think is supposed to reply
Knight C5 but can play a number of
things here but mvl I guess caught by
surprise a little bit by this Choice by
uh by uh lay he goes Knight takes A4 and
C5 which I always thought was sort of
very sensible but didn't entirely
equalize because the position you get
after Rook D1 she takes D4 and Knight
takes D4 it's it looks like yeah even is
but generally speaking when there is a
knight on D4 against a knight on
B8 uh you end up having to play
precisely to uh to minimize the the
slight pressure that white probably has
here it's not bad I I'm not going to
suggest that mvl has committed some kind
of an unforgivable sin here not going
for the sharper options but this never
really inspired me very much as a black
player because I think you are only
really trying to make a draw here and
you might even have to work a little bit
for it after uh that came Bishop G4 F3
Bishop
D7 F3 Bishop D7 and queen a
and yeah this is a very typical
structure where if you give white time
to play let's say Bishop C4 even Bishop
B2 and then Castle short and black still
has no comfortable way of playing Knight
C6 I think you will start feeling like
you're in a lot of trouble and the
current issue is of course if Knight C6
white will take GRE and the bishop on D7
is pinned meaning that you absolutely
have to recapture with the pawn and this
is just not pleasant at all no uh and
how do you avoid it yeah you would like
to play Queen C8 and Knight C6 but you
don't want to hang your E7 is hanging
yeah so let's say I can even maybe wait
for a move yeah maybe we could take on
E7 immediately as well yeah so I was
going to say I'm going to have to play
Queen C8 Tanya with the inclusion of a
move Rook E8 that's a Tempo I don't want
to throw that is extremely slow I'm not
happy you you could start running into
serious trouble because let's say I go
Bishop C4 I also force you to play go
back either go back or play 76 and I'm
not Happ say I go Knight B5 I'm not
happy maybe we're still sort of okay
after Bishop takes B5 but none of this
is a dream right none of this is a dream
it's not what groomfield players aspire
to not particularly very often that uh
you're able to take Maxim vasher lra by
surprise in a gr field that is for sure
and I think for Liam it has been a bit
of an opening success getting this
position where black still has to solve
the problem of development and we see
that Max not sure about how to get that
Knight to C6 has made the waiting the
seemingly waiting move A6 how does this
help the cause of development I have a
feeling that maybe he is trying to
prepare to play 7 E5 my question would
be if you are so worried about the night
landing on the B5 Square have you
actually stopped it would be my question
no uh and yeah the my current answer is
no I don't really I guess his point is
he will play Knight now the Knight is
hanging yes it's a very nice square but
this is also a very nice square and this
is suddenly becoming a much more
manageable proposition dnam but the
bigger problem is what if white says no
I'm not going to let you have any fun at
all and just goes Knight B3 and then
after you've accompl you have to worry
about Knight C5 you have to worry about
Queen D6 and also you've killed off your
own pride and joy the bishop G7 is no
longer playing Bishop E2 to the question
The Gauntlet is uh taken up once again
and again these two players tied in
second place it's a pivotal pivotal game
uh you whoever comes out of this one
Victor is really uh happy man going into
the last game of the rapid let's go uh
Around the Horn a little bit we're going
to go to the game of an nishe and Fabby
this looks like a position I've actually
seen very recently for some reason it's
a position that I played very recently
in the man yes the idea of A5 A4 A5 A4 I
really like it with black the black side
yes I was black so why did you want your
Pawn on A4 Tanya so the idea here is
that of course white has the option to
stop that by pushing the a pawn
themselves which they can do with A4
which leads to very different kind of
positions as well in Clans but here if
black does if white rushes with the
other plan of rerouting the Knight to G3
what black wants to do is create
counterplay on the queen side so you are
at some point threatening to go A3 okay
even if it means sacrificing a pawn
because taking on A3 just destroys the
pawn structure on the other hand the
other uh plan of A5 A4 of course the A3
idea is a bit more obvious is this move
Bishop D7 Knight A5 as you're pointing
out is now a big threat with the B5
Square under control the A4 Pawn
defended and sometimes we also see a
really interesting Queen maneuver the
queen from d8 can come to B8 can come to
A7 and start targeting the F2 Pawn uh
and these are the different plans that
black has to try to create play on The
Queen side with this A5 Pawn expansion
nice so there you're seeing uh some nice
uh opening uh thank you Tanya and what's
their head to head let's take a look
Anish giri and Fabiano Carana two very
good friends off the board close close
fight have played against each other a
number of times but right now it is
Fabby who leads their head to head with
nine wins and it's only six wins to
Anish uh 33% better score nicely done uh
Victory uh Knight E7 was played uh by
the way to avoid what you have spoken
about the avoid losing the two Bishops
to Knight C6 to A5 Bishop B5 Knight E7
the light squared Bishops were extracted
from the board interesting uh Dance of
the knights both players getting their
Knights to G6 and G3 Bishop E3 and
immediate
captures and you know Peter it's it's
always been funny to my mind I was
taught that when you give up the you s
they actually called it surrendering the
center you surrender the center you were
supposed to play D5 like almost always
now you just surrender the center and
you leave them there yeah what's going
on I think it's just tactical here
because after Bishop B3 there is a
positional threat of taking on E5 and
taking on B6 spoiling the black
structure and there's no comfortable way
of dealing with it like moves like Rook
A6 or queen C6 don't really look all
that great artificial and I just want to
point out that I absolutely have no
memory of this whatsoever but I lost
this position to Peter Leo in 2020
apparently really I have no memory of it
well very good you have put it out of
your uh database I I wish I could I
could claim that this is you know proper
management of positive mindset I just
have no memory of things uh it's it's
not really me being such a sunny and
positive person it's right that's the
way it is yeah so ed4 p recaptured with
the c and actually most people here
there four games here including some
reasonably high rated ones and every
single person here took with the pawn so
Bishop takes D4 is technically a novelty
by an is this is logical Queen B5 is
also quite logical activating the queen
reminding white that the pawn on B2
could be potentially a Target Queen C2
Rook a C8 I like the move Rook E3
because the other Rook will come into
E1 protecting the E4 E4 Pawn the oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah Peter Leo yes uh
Peter and Peter Leo and our Peter yes
both Peters yeah yeah Peter Leo uh so
apparently you just put that game out of
your mind but uh I I'm trying to
remember which which event that was
maybe something online 2020 it probably
was something online online yeah which
is why it's not as indelibly itched into
my into my but if I'm looking at this
position etched yeah if I'm looking at
this position I'm liking white I I I
have everything I have the center I have
more control I have
you know the Rover and I can double I
can switch I can go Rook A3 reminding
you I can go Rook A3 Rook C3 I can play
for D5 Knight come on what is white do
what what is black doing why is black
happy I I don't know if he is I think
the suggestion here for for black would
be my position is still solid apart from
the slightly extended Pawn on A4 I
present no targets to play against we
can play something like C7 C6 here
because I would be a little bit worried
about allowing D5 Knight D4 maybe
switching it over to F5 because you can
actually imagine white launching an
attack on the king side if you if you
allow it and then let's say after the
move C7 C6 you you you ask white how are
you making progress here but it also
kind of invites Knight F5 we weakened
the pawn on D6 a little bit so I would
be very very happy here with white I
would know my advantage is not huge but
I also know that I am by far the more
comfortable of the of the two players
here so absolutely Absol absolutely well
we're going to keep an eye on this we're
going to go uh Around the Horn we're
just going to jump in on the game of Sam
uh seon and my pick by the way uh Ali
Raza which after his loss to Ray Robson
in his failure to to uh get Wesley it's
kind of drifting uh we'll see if he
repairs in time for the blitz what have
we got here uh T did you keep an eye on
her yes it is a Brer it is a Brer we got
the Spanish which was answered by the BR
by black which involves retreating the
Knight to B8 to reroute it and this is
the position the current position where
we see a lot of dark Square targets for
that black knight to jump into white on
the other hand is playing against the
Bishops that black has that Bishop on f8
right now out of the game the bishop on
B7 blocked as well uh but I feel that
and I don't know what you're thinking is
but I think alira should be pleased with
this uh opening out the knights are
jumping into the game the B file is
there to try to take control of uh I'm
kind of liking I wouldn't say that black
is better but I it feels to me that
black has solved a lot of the opening
problems out of the bre which gives very
little space to Black it's one of those
uh positions where don't forget I do
have a central clamp right like if I can
you know maintain that for the for
Life maybe your pieces suffer a little
bit uh asphixiation like okay it is I'm
going to make a move Bishop D2 yeah and
you play a move like Knight C5 it does
look at first blush that you do have
things right okay I go Knight G4 now I'm
just going to do something badly right
takes takes um
unless th this is what I really want to
say as long as I keep my Center intact
for a long long long long long time uh
your pieces might get cramped there is
G4 G five so maybe both players are
happy I don't know I guess it's really
important for black to find Targets on
that C4 Pawn as you were pointing out
instead once your knight moves from E3
get the Rook onto the C file or the B
file uh yes but white black needs to
find counterplay on the queen side Peter
what is your take in this position who
is more pleased out of the opening uh I
think break the tie yeah Alo I think
should be quite happy because I think it
definitely was his choice to go for this
and I wanted to start with a little bit
of a
memory of mine and we've just
established I have none whatsoever but
uh challenge but still I I seem to
remember when alzo just started
appearing in these very very strong
tournaments he at some point lost a game
to Magnus where Magnus went for the
structure with the black pieces that's
right and outplayed him comprehensively
comprehensively and it looked like he
really understood where pieces belonged
he really understood the long-term plans
and ala was just shuffling and his
position just continued yes uh
it was a vikon and I think so one of the
earlier vikon tournaments where alzo
lost this with white very very
comprehensively as as you said and it's
interesting to see now and it feels
really weird right to say that ala is an
elder statement state statement in in
this game because he's older than than
Sam no he's 20 no Al how old is Sam I
think
22 close very close actually my my great
you're on a roll baby we're not going to
stop you I I I meant the correct thing
but I said the wrong thing right ala is
the elder State statman because he is uh
he is the stronger and the more
established player right uh so he is now
the examiner saying I understand the
structure better than you do I will be
doing the Magnus job here I will be out
playing you from what to begin with is a
slightly worse position frankly I played
a lot of this with both colors yeah if
white does their job well it's not that
much fun for black but right
it presents you with a very good
opportunity to play for a win eventually
because the position is extremely
complex okay double-edged position you
say white slightly better I noticed that
there's no master games which suggest to
me somebody made a novelty where and
when somewhere somewhere it I'm very
surprised this is already new supposedly
because there have to be games fibbe
actually had the position all the way up
to C4 in his game against D way back in
2016 and also uh I'm guessing this is a
game against bam maklu in 2020 so this
is a reasonably well-known position
there's a bunch of games from here but
A5 is uh A5 is already uh not a very
popular popular choice okay uh but all
of these positions sort of flow into
each other and uh by the way Bishop B2
on the board I'm a bit surprised by this
I don't know why that Bishop should
occupy that particular diagonal because
it's hitting in uh the pawn on E5 which
will be very difficult to sh I would
much rather put it on either G2 or E3
maybe exactly all right we keep for I
think it's really important to get these
kind of positions where it's still a
rich middle game it's a game for all
three results and playing with the black
pieces you find your you try to find
your play on The Queen side you try to
find your targets given the tournament
situation and the tour situation right
for ala I think to get this with black
pieces it is uh it is looking good but
still a long long way to go and could be
anyone's game let's continue with our
games and uh I have I we're getting an
update that one of our players is
already down on the clock and no prizes
for guessing who I'm going to go with
Ray Robson on this one and I was right
uh check it check it out uh the groom
fell defense and you mentioned that
after the move Bishop D7 Rook B1 Rook C8
white is enjoying his space and check
this move out H2 H4 would you like would
you like Aon uh you know I would like a
Pon but I also really like my
yes exactly but let's show it yes the
problem with getting greedy cookie uh on
offer should not be accepted as you will
end up either with Knight G3 or G4 Queen
H3 but Knight G3 feels like this easiest
path to and it is winning her highness
that's right so no captur no uh no
grabbing the pawn in fact uh black often
wants to trade Queens uh Peter yeah in
this line you you generally feel like
the the grinfield game will be quite
okay for you and white on the other hand
very often just declines this uh and
quein B2 is a very typical way to avoid
the queen trade and the clock times we
how bad is Ray's uh misuse of the clock
we've seen worse much worse we've seen
worse but I want to ask you yes because
you know Ray Robson so many years what
is it about his chess that what are his
strengths that when he's down to those
crucial minutes in positions which are
so complicated critical how is he able
to maintain his accuracy with just
seconds on the clock I have no idea I I
really don't know how they do it I I get
frazzled in time trouble uh a dear
friend of mine Victor kchoi Victor was
habitually in time trouble and he often
times played better when he was under
the pressure of the clock like he would
sit at the board think for an hour and
play something that you kind of think to
yourself why did you even come up up
with that whereas when he was under the
pressure of the ticking clock his
accuracy his calculation was Sublime and
Ry actually so impressive it really
really is I mean you almost want to say
to Ray Ray don't play rapid chess you're
going to get five minutes and 10 seconds
per move and he'd probably be in time
trouble as well yeah it's been just
amazing to watch him handle those
situation and speaking of good friends
in time trouble Peter your good friend
Alexander G I can't imagine a bigger
example a legend and when he's playing
on seconds I mean his chess is just God
LEL chess how does he do it you build
tolerance I suppose I I don't really
know I've played next to him in team
events and it's it's a
very difficult experience to to watch
him do it but he more often than not he
would come out he would come out
smelling of roses when when the time
control is reached and uh yeah I don't
know for me I I wouldn't I wouldn't be
able to do it for a small fraction of
the of the career that he's had
seemingly having horrible time troubles
in every game I'm in all of it I have
this image of myself as well I'm playing
on an Olympic team with Walter Brown so
we've got you know five members of the
team horrified like taser watching
Walter Brown in a frenzy time scramble
coming up as you said smelling like a
rose and you know coming out you know
adjusting his TI how how was it guys and
we're all
collapsing we want to
kill we need to ask r at the end of how
do you do it tell us about the current
position of Ray if you don't mind I mean
we talk about his time trouble but let's
talk about the position well only only a
couple of moves were added after Queen
bitsu the engine was suggesting you
could uh go for immediate
uh simplifications with Knight E5
seemingly like a temporary P sacrifice
attacking the uh Bishop C and this seems
to work out fine for black but it also
simplifies the position to such a degree
that I think Yan who needs a win here I
think Yan is generally in general a very
very ambitious player he preserves play
by playing rook fd8 and now after Rook
fc1 also a very logical move defending
the bishop defending the bishop just
strengthening your position in general
uh it feels like white should have a
small Edge but uh all to play for I
would say there's uh it's it's still a
very complicated position which cannot
be simplifi to a few senten I feel like
the move H2 H4 is a jab you just want to
kind of throw it out there you want to
play H5 but with Queen on
A5 should I that does a very good job of
stopping it it also supports the idea of
sometimes maybe playing bishop3 G5
attacking that Rook on d8 because it's a
very good Square for the rook and he
would like for black to move it away
from it so for instance Bishop f8 now is
an interesting option presenting white
with this interesting uh problem of how
to deal with the threat of Bishop of 8
A3 scaring the uh the queen and the r on
C1 and to this you could reply for
instance with the move Bishop G5 and
then you could you could get this really
strange funny funny line where
everything gets picked up and supposedly
this ends up being fine for black after
all of these pieces come off the board
and you get a very standard grinfield
end game where if this Pawn was already
on H6 Alpha zero this maybe would have
been a bit annoying but it's not and
it's not going to get there black will
be in time to stop it from from
appearing on H6 this is not not bad at
all uh the Yan prefers Bishop F6 though
and I think once again Yan wants to
preserve as many pieces on the board as
possible so I think for him it's much
more interesting to to play with with
the Queens on okay The Logical reply
here would be to play Bishop F2 I don't
think we want to give up on H4 just yet
and H5 as you as you said is not really
available because the the queen controls
the fifth rank so I'm expecting Bishop
F2 and then I very much would like to
know how to Yan how Yan wants to
continue from exactly uh Tanya where
would you like us to go let's uh head
over to Anish and Fabby next we will
keep an eye out on the tournament leader
of course and jump straight back but
check it out looks in a zit position at
Z yes and we left to tell it started
with an it with an Italian I think and
we were looking at this earlier when
Anish went with this A5 A4 plan and yes
again you know we were a bit critical
about Black's position thinking that
white has more space more Rook activity
but I really like the way Fabby has
shown the path he instead went for the
C5 idea in the center which fixes the
center and then managed to create a past
Pawn past Pawn SL weakness I don't know
what to call it but it it does give
black dis play and a really nice hold on
the D3 Square which he's uh just done
he's just managed to land his KN on D3
and it was in the 1990s that anat kpof
was playing the zyf and he would get
positions very similar to this Peter and
and even in the matches in the mid 80s I
think already in those matches you would
see them discussing these types of
structures in seemingly every second
game and a very very interesting thing
has just happened after kn9 D3 there's a
rook hanging on E1 an says I don't care
because I would like to give mate on the
king side if you take on E1 I will play
Rook G3 and look at that mass G7 is
hanging Queen takes H6 is also a oh
Knight H5 you go Queen H6
anywhere absolutely and we are breaking
through as you can see complete collapse
black maybe void made but we'll get
completely wiped off the board and on
occasion this did happen to carof not
that often not not every not every
single game but and supposedly you have
to play King h8 here and I had a strange
experience here because I I saw the
engine suggesting this move and I
thought why doesn't this simply lose to
Knight takes G7 King takes G7 Rook G3
check King H7 and Knight F5 has to be
has to be Ali Reza's sacrifice and then
I because actually it took me a while to
realize Ian is hanging again and and and
then and then I remembered and black
just stops the mate and also collects
all of all of the pieces this is just
completely lost for white right so after
King h8 sadly for an Nish it appears
that you have to actually start
Defending Your your material and after
Rani to Black can make an immediate a
draw with Knight F4 and Knight D3 and he
might have to because I think the threat
of Rook G3 is so strong that not
availing yourself of the opportunity to
make a draw right this moment might be
you might never have another one wow I
have a feeling that if you give white a
move here either Knight takes G7 or R G3
will be a decisive can you try to
continue with a move like Knight
H5 I just want to keep the game going so
that I can maybe one day create Chances
with the the seep on are you sure you're
not allowing
N7 very scary I'm looking at even in
this position I'm looking at n G7 Knight
G7 Rook G3 and if King H7 I'm looking at
this and you will have to give up the
queen but the issue is maybe maybe
you're happy maybe you're actually
surviving again with the move C3 here
and C2 incredible lines but you have you
have to be very very sure of yourself we
have played Knight H5 immediately did
not play
yeah he didn't play King h8 and he went
KN H5 directly and
that that the whole Queen s side by the
way has just somehow been magically
cleansed but Knight
H5
really I'm looking that that's a foul
move come on what I like Knight H5 what
what it takes control of the G3 Squad
that wait a minute that's all wrong okay
what do you do if I go Queen D1 don't
ask me these questions but all right
let's where your going um so I'm scared
to take on E1 I will admit that Knight
takes Rook you want to take your knight
and then you're coming on Rook G3
correct that's the that's that is a very
interesting option actually like this
shall we cheat not yet not yet yet let's
try and find a more human approach to
Queen to D1 so your idea is Queen G4
next for example I think we should show
that Knight F4 Queen G4 you're not
really turning the M on G7 but Knight 86
is a massive TR you mentioned her
highness yes which dis PS for black in
this case right uh Queen to D1 what are
the options do you I have to defend my
knight on H5 I need Peter I need you to
help me here okay now we cheat um we
don't need to cheat we have Peter yes
that's cheating now that the queen is
now that the queen is not controlling
the H6 I'm wondering if I can afford to
play Knight F6 and maybe Rook G3 is no
longer mate but no it is it's still mate
let me que D1 well
guys yeah I I had a feeling G6 might
work but I was very worried that we will
just take on and then we will go back to
F5 and intention and I would just kind
of strip you of one of your uh E1 is
hanging so the computer suggests giving
up on H6 with check but now both this
Knight and the Rook on E1 is are hanging
and this is a playable position for
white you continue by taking on D3 and
then either playing Knight G4 or perhaps
even playing this Qui move Queen D2 for
now and then dropping back to G4 okay
this is a very interesting option but
the thing zeros yeah the thing about
Knight H5 though compared to the move
King h8 which we were discussing earlier
is that after King h8 The Rook has to
stay on the E file because otherwise you
lose the pawn on e4 whereas Knight H5
releas releases that pressure and you
can actually use more of the board ah
releases the pressure on the
E4 so you can actually play something
like Rook B1 or Rook A1 and continue the
game in that direction creates a threat
of B6 perhaps attacking the pawn on D6
which is often vulnerable so the whole
difference is the Knight on H5 releases
the pressure on e4 releases The Rook
from his guard Duty and was a dangerous
position Queen D1 I love that
movie yeah just to wow um let I don't
somehow I feel like we haven't gone
through all of the games uh Jeffrey Jang
Wesley so two players who uh haven't uh
really shined uh this far what have we
got here uh isolated Queen Pawn
looks very nice for white but how do you
follow up what's your knee-jerk uh
feelings about this position Tanya I'm
not going to I'm going to be honest here
while you were looking at this position
and we will stay on this but I have my
eye out on the tournament leader you're
going to love what's happening there but
first let's get a quick Roundup of this
position because perhaps it's not the
most important game for our standings
not the most important but interesting
situation going on on here okay
it's it's it's it's so Bishop to D7 I I
feel it's very double-edged you have a
rook on B6 you're hitting that pawn on
A6 tying Down The Rook that's right
Black's got the bishop on D7 eyeing the
A4 Knight we will see how this develops
of course but I am really wanting to get
your attention on Yan's and Ray robson's
matchup because crazy things are
happening on the board Bishop F6 Bishop
F2 as you prescribed Peter B7
yeah Queen Bishop B1 here played very
logical move here just uh stopping Queen
takes B7 Bishop E1 where's your queen
going by the way and Y went with Queen
H5 which I wonder if this was connected
with some kind of a miscalculation
because he had the option of playing
Queen A4 it wasn't losing any material
it looks like you might be losing your
queen to Bishop B5 but now that the
white Bishop is not on F2 anymore you
can play even Queen takes D4 check
actually which is a style points move
exactly because you are winning back you
win the queen back and you seemingly are
completely fine and after Queen A4 if
white does something for a move you you
go Knight A5 and you secure your queen
position because you cover all the
squares from which it can be attacked
exactly but instead he played Queen H5
which is an incredibly provocative
option and it was met by a very
understandable G4 G5 I think well down a
piece yeah it's not just winning a piece
for two pawns but it's winning the dark
squared Bishop that's that's a huge
minor piece to win for two pawns sorry
no absolutely what you're saying
everything that and yes you've blown
open your opponent uh King side the king
looks weak but where are the pieces
exactly there is absolutely no
assistance to that Queen on the king
side no other Rook no Rook is joining
the attack there are no potential Rook
lifts the H and the g lines can in fact
at time be even used by white to get to
the black sking absolutely no I see this
as uh material and compensation for
white I love Ray's position I think this
is just outstanding for white also look
at the clock situation yes it is 18
minutes to Yan again a sign that he
rushed up a critical moment that move
that Peter was pointing out the queen uh
Queen to A4 where he quickly played
Queen H5 inviting and forcing himself
into this position uh less than 18
minutes he started thinking now but it
might be too late to take that pause wow
well I'm seeing a little coffee house
chess here by Yan is he's just throwing
caution to the wind beater I don't like
it at all for black yeah that that
seemed a little a little too gamly to to
my eyes and in particular because there
were there were off really good alnaes
off ramps available que A4 is a pretty
decent option here and yes you have to
calculate but these are not very
difficult
calculations and we're being told that
Queen H5 didn't really take him all that
much time to to to to play and honestly
this position just looks horrible
horrible the the way maybe that he
thought he can continue here is the move
B6 B5 trying to disrupt the uh the
coordination of the white pieces but
regrettably you can even play Bishop D3
which I think is really rubbing salt
into the wounds point being that if you
win that Bishop your queen is still you
it costs you a full Queen on uh on that
square so and if you don't play B5 if
you give white time to play something
like King G1 F2 you're not going to be
able to anything even you're just down a
piece and white has a very very secure
conversion in front of him our highness
is having a hard time in this particular
game I want to go back to the game of
Fabby for a moment because Anish Sheri
is apparently gone for that variation
that you talked about Peter which was
sacrificing The Exchange on D3 winning
the pawn on H6 and just having uh
tremendous compensation for the exchange
uh take us to the current position if
you don't mind uh the interesting point
there came a few moves earlier where uh
after night H5 Anish has gone for
something we did not really discuss
properly because he gave up this
exchange immediately without waiting for
any further provocation he just took on
D3 twice and in response Fabi just gave
up on H6 also with more or less no no
addition something like something like
King
H7 is definitely at least an option but
he just played G6 and and then uh King
H7 perhaps intention was to meet Knight
G4 with
F5 but Anish as in the variation we were
discussing earlier goes Queen D2 for now
right and now Knight G4 is a massive
massive threat because it will
immediately create the idea of the queen
coming to H6 with a check uh this looks
uh very unpleasant for black you know
these are the type of M positions that
machines hold and you just shake your
head like in despair but humans collapse
in these positions Knight G4 Queen H6 is
just
such a huge even hf5 might be a very
strong threat because once once the
queen lands on H6 you can you can invest
a lot of material into landing your your
queen on H6 and be quite happy about it
you're not even up materially it's a
rook for a night and two pawns two PS
and your king is weak I don't even
believe that the machines would be happy
and I see our evaluation there it gives
a big advantage to White here exactly
the weak black king and also there are
tactics right after your knight goes
back to uh G4 in these positions we see
are B there the queen jumping into H6
has a really nasty idea it's not just a
check you're actually threatening maybe
we can show that Rook C5 uh take it away
Tanya yeah Knight and let's make a move
like Rook to C8 here doubling up I was
thinking doubling up but all right just
to show the idea Queen a
six check got to go back and maybe there
are other options but the one that
strikes to me as the simplest is simply
grab the Knight get rid of the defender
Knight jumps on to F6 and this end game
has got to be winning for white G it's
just gone yeah uh Knight Queen takes H5
reminds me of the queen takes F5 by Ali
Raza uh from yesterday that Al W if you
missed that game please go back and have
a look any Queen F5 ever on from now is
the alira move officially exactly um
there are issues uh that Fabby is facing
how does a computer deal with this night
engine goes Rook C4 and after Knight G4
goes King G8 preventively to uh by
attacking the Knight on D4 to make it
harder for white to play Queen H6 and
continue the attack but we as as Tanya
said white is in fact I think ahead on
on material count so you can make some
kind of a useful waiting move like and
just say okay show me show me why you
think you're doing any good at all here
and we can continue improving perhaps F
two F3 just supporting the pawn on e4 is
a useful continuation getting ready to
play Knight C6 ready to play Queen
H6 to play Knight F5 all of those things
are absolutely in the air on on every
single move here and it's just very very
difficult to play for black as you can
see the engine suggests we can attack
the KN on D D4 again but white can and
shoot play KN see that on the board
visually it just looks so good for it's
very very dangerous for black the engine
somehow how does this doesn't resile
it's a take on F5 beo what is the what
is blow what are the ideas of these
sacrifices and very simply we
reestablish an night on Five this is and
then it comes in and it gives mate yeah
so you give one Knight to put your other
Knight on it yeah on F5 yeah those
setups with7 played by Fabby in the
meantime another decent defensive move
trying to keep keep pieces closer to the
dark squares perhaps after Knight G4 you
will be able to put the queen on f8 in
some positions stop the landing on KN G4
Queen f8 in in fact this this has
already happened yeah queen4 Queen f8 so
Queen coming over to just defend the
king with Queen E7 Queen f8 and it just
feels like you're you're you're you're
you're primed and ready for a blow uh
Queen
G5 Knight F5 I'm thinking about what you
said even if it's not a blow you put
that Knight on C6 and you just feel so
good about your position right that
Black Knight on H5 is far away from
getting into the game no knight7 no kn
yeah two pawns I remember having these
adjourn games uh in uh Olympics Olympiad
but whenever the adjournment was in my
favor I had like 12
Cooks they would all come over show me
how I should win whenever I was worse
they just leave me no one's there to
help you but when you're winning boy
then everybody wants to jump in this
looks like a very nice position for
Anish all the games in play Peter what's
let's caught your eye I'm not sure where
to go I I want to slightly give my
opinion on the game we didn't really
discuss properly and I no longer really
have to give my opinion here it's pretty
clearly going to be a fairly fairly
equal game but even in the position that
you were discussing you said your
initial reaction was that white is doing
really well but honestly with the
Bishops as active as they are the bishop
on G7 in particular supporting the D4 D5
D5 D4 break whenever these Knights are
traded with Queen A3 coming in my
impression was that actually white needs
to be quite careful here I didn't really
I felt that uh if anyone is in any
danger of being worse here it was more
white than black even though of course
equality is the more likely outcome and
the decision by uh Jeffrey to go Rook B6
B1 here I think is an indication of what
he thought about this position as well
because he felt that keeping things
under control leaving the B6 Square for
the night perhaps to land on uh is the
way to go and then some trades happen
happened and and yeah this this should
this should even out okay you normally
expect D5 and D4 somehow to get traded
with and the draw too uh has Oli raaza
shown himself to be the professor uh
versus Sam Sean saying I got some
lessons from Magnus Carlson let me show
you what I've learned and the players
have reached an imbalance of two Bishops
but a very I want to say a nice Outpost
for this night on 5 and we've caught up
to the players uh how do you how does
the computer like this pretty even
pretty pretty pretty even ACC according
to the engine but I think it's easier to
play for black because I think for
instance the plan of playing E5 E4 here
and then trying to trade the dark Square
Bishops along the the long diagonal and
leaving yourself with this Knight on C5
against this bishop on C2 if you if you
manage to do all that without losing any
material in the proc I think you will be
extremely happy once again good night
the heartless engine suggests everything
everything in life is equal but some
positions are more equal than others
absolutely I would I would be choosing
black here any day of the week for sure
exactly uh let's jump back to Ray Robson
and versus Jan because when we left it
we thought that uh Yan was being way way
too optimistic and he did play the
B5 and he expanded on the queen side but
I don't get it me neither and he took
quite a bit of time after giving up that
piece and I'm just wondering is it
something he missed when he went Queen
H5 did because it's not a position that
you go willingly into no it's not
something that you desire to get into
this pce sacrifice me sacrifice my dark
squared Bishop for two pawns no and for
no actual attack against the king so
what is it my best guess is he thought
Queen A4 was losing maybe he thought E5
blocking the diagonal and then Bishop B5
wins the queen but it doesn't because we
have Bishop B7
and that gives us the A3 Square so I it
must have been some kind of a
miscalculation uh I'm not entirely sure
what kind but yeah I I don't think he
believed this is any good I think I
think he's experienced enough to know to
know that this this is never any good
right and he spent so much time in the
position right after giving up that
piece even before he played the move B5
that does indicate that this is not this
is not part of the plan for Yan no but
by the way once again boldly State the
obvious for Ray Robson he's almost in
disbelief how marvelous things are going
he's leading the tournament he's playing
one of the strongest Grand Masters in
the world a twice Challenger in uh in uh
Yan and he knows he's winning the game
and it's like guys you know you're
giving me the first place here thank you
for this you know like this is just like
amazing it's going to be a lot about
nerves for me right now to not only
believe what is happening but also keep
you know the clock situation he's
winning this position he wins this game
he's looking so good to get that rapid
championship of the St Louis fantastic
and by the way uh I mean I'm sitting
here in raos and trust me when I'm
saying you know like I'm finding myself
all excited but I'm looking at this
position and I'm thinking to myself
aren't I just taking over the game with
the move Rook C5 and for me this move A2
A3 is saying you know okay I'm just
keeping an eye on A4
but was Rook C5 not a clanker uh or I
think he's trying to to keep things as
much under control as possible and I
think he likes the bishop on this
diagonal because eventually I think D4
D5 will be an important resource for him
but it's also very difficult to go wrong
and as you can see I my eye was actually
drawn to this move because because of
Bishop H4 Bishop H4 is a massive threat
which I don't even know if if black can
meet by the way the queen on B2
Intimates that Rook H6 s Rook
hook so Rook H1 was winning on the spot
your move Rook C5 I'm pretty sure is
also just completely winning followed by
let's say Rook bc1 next that was the
positional approach right but we're not
going to criticize A3 and we've had
moves after A3 B4 was played and Ray
Robson keeps the pawns on the board so
makes a decision to go A4 and I like it
because it also in some positions some
end games that a pawn might come handy
A5 might be weak H5 played and this
invites the idea of rookie H1 that
you've been pointing out or Rook C5 Rook
C5 was chosen yeah no he's he's very
much in control here and by his
standards he has a minute and a half
there should be too much
time luxury absolute absolute luxury for
him yeah he should be winning this game
yeah so that is a very huge result there
two players who are tied for second uh
they're crossing swords that's mvl and
Liam I'm jumping to that game it looks
very very
balanced we're not going to spend too
much time on this yeah we expect a draw
there where's the action Peter pretty
much everywhere else um we've spoken
about the game between Ray and Jan at
length in giri against Fabby there was a
very critical moment a moment ago we
left it uh in this position yeah Knight
of3 is a very strong move here by Anish
I very much like it and the engine also
loved it Queen G7 and E5 is also correct
just breaking the position open in the
center but after d Tak C5 he had to see
a very very beautiful geometrical
solution here the solution here was to
give a check to ignore the pawn on E5 Al
together push D5 D6 I'm pretty sure he
saw up to here sure and he probably
didn't find a way to break through and
the engine goes Queen A2 in this
position and says I want to take on F7 I
want to play Knight H6 check and things
start collapsing I want to avoid Queen
D5 and allowing you to play Knight F6 I
really just want to play Knight F7
Knight F7 is yeah Rook D6 Knight F7 just
loses on the spot because everything
starts starts falling apart the engine
tries to play Rook D7 but then we go
Queen A4 and things continue
collapsing yeah Rook but understanding
that you're basically winning in this
position I don't think it's I don't
think it's very easy no because not at
all yes it looks attractive and I guess
the threat is eventually maybe Knight if
Knight F4 maybe Knight E4 is very strong
with Knight G6 ideas but
wow to to to recognize just how winning
you are here yeah that that is not not
obvious that is not easy at all and
queen A2 as well as uh it's not an easy
move and then at the end of these few
moves to feel you've just given up a
pawn and you're still clearly winning
not an easy human task Cent position
what he did is completely understandable
he took on E5 with the KN but that
allowed Fabby to get some pieces off the
board just and white is still going to
be making all the running because of
difference in King safety more than
anything anything else okay but this is
this represents a massive Improvement in
fabi's fortunes because he's no longer
really getting mated some attacking
pieces have gotten off the board this
probably is defendable now yeah Fab's
got to be relieved right now that was a
position where it looked like a night
fork or a night jump a night check would
be just game over but that's not
happening let's jump back to our
tournament leader Ray Robson we think
Ray is in absolute cruise control he has
a piece for two pawns but it's all about
the clock as we see 40 seconds and you
have to get the job done you know you're
playing against a very tricky player
yeahi he can be so resourceful setting
up those trps and with 30 seconds yes
Reay has shown incredible chess with
seconds on the clock uh but he still got
to get the job done and it's not over
but Yan there shaking his head well
Yan's realized that the move Bishop F4
set up Bishop F4 G5 skewering the rook
and he had to put his Queen on the h8
Square a clear indication that this is
absolutely absolutely terrible now the
question is how you know we we very much
want to play the move d4 D5 and not
blunder Our Queen uh raise down
to 20 seconds touching the 20 second
Mark now H1 did we like this move it's
perfectly fine yeah the pawn on H4 now
is a very legit legitimate Target on H4
Bishop G very strong Rook takes H4 is on
raise if he wins this game Tanya my gosh
that would give him a three-point lead
which is uncatchable because you get it
depends on the other boards and where
they finish CU you get two points for a
win you're absolutely right Liam might
draw with mvl that would mean that Ray
has a fourpoint lead with one game one
game to go and he's so close to it and
this felt like a bit of a gift from Yan
walking into that Queen H5 giving up
that piece exactly what you're hoping
and dreaming
for and as we've seen before uh history
says it tradition says it in the St
Louis the rapid and Blitz you win the
rapid you win the
tournament I got to tell you I don't
think the bookies will agree because you
got one formidable Ali Raza fou is the
number one rated Blitz player in the
world ahead of Magnus Carlson that says
something so I mean has got all the work
cut out for him but he's enjoying life
and he's just played this move Rook H1
which sets up Bishop G5 H3 a kind of
like I very much like the idea of
including the king in the game here you
want to play King G3 I wanted to play
King G3 but there is a Cheo maybe based
on Knight D4 ah that was the trick yeah
that is that is he Retreats with the
Queen instead so pinning that Knight on
C6 no more night jumps The Rook hangs
and see it and guess what that releases
the Deep pawn and now the move d4 D5
breaking bursting open the
diagonal also uh just let me point out
what Peter uh we love including the king
but King G3 did allow Knight takes D4 it
was still F Rook L C8 here I I think
still wins but I I like win C1 I
actually think ra
strong I win a lot all right but we've
got moves on the board instead I think
Queen C1 I like it E5 played and Yan is
playing on the clock right now that is
his only hope it's clear he has to keep
playing fast putting the pressure on
Ray's clock well he now he's in Swindle
mode absolutely but after something like
Bishop D5 it's just so difficult to see
where the counterplay will come from
there's just nothing in Ray's position
to attack this visibly reminds me of
Ray's game with Ali Raza where he put
his pieces on squares massive squares
Knight C Knight C6 Bishop E6 Rook G6
Queen H all of the all of White's pieces
are like on ideal squares Queen H
probably missed because I definitely
missed it I was about to say it actually
Queen H5 is the only move that creates a
threat and Knight G did you see that he
played in no with one second R oh my
goodness I think y leaning back there
thinking how did you not lose on time
there the Knight G1 defends F3 very
importantly and it sets up for Rook
takes H3 this is is like perfectly timed
he still keeping things under control
but yeah moving making that move on 1
second it was so close and we've seen
we've seen Sam savan on the receiving
end of that one second okay but this
move unfortunately for for Jan he wants
to play a move like Knight
D4 uh but but it's it feels like it's
just going to be one check I think I can
take on C8 playing E1 that's the problem
Rook into Pawn is a big threat no sorry
what what what should I do I was
thinking like if you go Knight D4 Rook
into Pawn is hanging as well he takes on
and can you take on H3 or does that run
into like more checks on G4 and we've
got a result on another board maxer gra
Liam ends in a draw we should go back to
but we have to rush backook our match up
no no playing any uh joking games and
allowing Rook F3 what do you got what do
you got I I think you have to start by
taking on C5 and then C5 I want to play
Rook takes
F3 F3 check yeah but I think Knight
takes F3 but why not with the okay I was
thinking you could take with the Rook
then Queen of3 and Knight D3 check I
think this is cleaner actually oh that
is oh look at you with your cheap
because this end game we might even save
on a good day because we also pick up
the pawn on A4 and there's going to be
only one left it's probably still lost
but maybe you you get you get yourself
some could it you you you covered
yourself nicely with the move Knight
takes
F3 and let's just see with the magic of
Replay how close two seconds and he made
a move just in
time it touched one and he pressed the
clock right how do I mean it's right
there it's Instinct there's something
very special about how they how these
players do that and hand with a slight
Shake of his head as soon as he pressed
the clock oh I almost had you
right but Rook takes H3 huge move Knight
takes E5 and again
Yan's he his mind is screaming where's
my Cheapo where's my Cheapo he's looking
for the trick right now he's looking for
anything that makes Ray Robson pause and
think even if it's not working exactly
any the line that we discussed is the
best chance black has here but
unfortunately Ray will be able to make a
lot of moves in a row very quickly and
also the position stabilizes and that
end game probably still lost so Yan
clearly is looking for anything else but
I don't think there is anything else ex
exactly I don't think so no and if I go
Rook C5 Queen C5 that
inclusion no TR no tricks here gosh darn
it Rook takes Rook Queen takes rook and
then Rook takes Pawn is the best
possible way for black ahead but even
that falls shot exactly in the lines
that we've just been discussing and Yan
it's really just important for him to
find something that doesn't give these
forcing options to us and look at this
Rook C3 trying to trying to keep all the
tricky Rees try to the unfortunately for
Jan his own Queen is
trapped takes C8 he does it Rook takes
Rook on the board and with Rook takes C8
we're threatening to take a bishop with
check and then to take the queen so does
black have time to jump in with the
Knight he does it it's a fork we can go
King G even there are no chicks King G3
looks best yeah King G3 looks best and
Ray making the T making the time he's M
I think he's just seconds away from
actually a victory right now exactly and
what a victory it will be I mean his his
moment in the sun is really outstanding
and Yan I think is realizing that he's
running out of cheapos all the tricks
that were possible I
mean what can you say he was down to a
second and here you go Knight takes F4
let's let let let's throw in some and
then takes and Rook takes E8 check has
done and queen takes the night and we
have got handshakes Ray Robson does it
he takes the win against
yishi wow unbelievable tip your hat and
he made it with one second to go Peter
is that happened in your experience have
you ever made a a Time control with one
second I must have at some point but I
have no defining memory of that
happening people have done this against
me as well and it's just such a
heartbreaking
experience why why can't why can't you
just lose
on L just lose oh oh boy there's still
some games running we still got action
on what's happening with uh Anish and
Fabby a fun position a really fun
position to watch but not so much to
play no no no no puns no PS left but I
think I think uh Fabby surv from here
because white will have to move the king
somewhere and then I guess you step away
from all of the for kn7 was a trick and
maybe we can just quickly show that
actually that it's really important
because you step away from the check and
let's say if something like5 happens you
have 97 check here with Bishop take
Queen takes G6 coming up but yeah this
will not be
blundered king H7 on the board as you
said and Rook takes E3 now is a threat
because the queen on D3 is uh hanging
and Knight E7 is no longer available
that would have been actually a better
line to show after King F1 why can't we
take on E3 here for the same reason very
nicely for the same reason I noticed
that the the the engine went from plus4
to only plus seven when you played Rook
takes E3 instead of Rook E5 because you
did get a knight after all we did get a
knight there yeah you mentioned that
Rook takes Knight as a big threat here
but does white have time to actually
just ignore it and start pushing the
Deep Pawn what this is the big question
yeah I think we can take anyway and take
on F5 because we have a threat of Knight
G3 Follow by C3 uh F takes E3 again we
can't recapture as we would desire
because of Queen takes D3 and Knight
takes F5 that's the problem Tanya we've
got this nasty threat of Knight G3
discovering against the queen as well as
the pawn and he calculates it and he
side steps with the queen queen C2 so
with the move Queen C2 however now we
are ready to meet Rook takes E3 with
Knight takes E3 thank you that means the
Knight defends the queen yep and I do
have three connected P not three
connected I have three pawns and you
have none ha Queen C2 maybe with even
ideas of Knight takes G G7 Peter in
these positions with the split pawns a
knight and two split pawns versus The
Rook there's no problem that's a very
easy draw I mean you forget about it
even even three I think even against
three you probably make a draw but you
don't enjoy it right you would like
something cleaner so what your
discussing is if the Queens got off the
board and it was just Knight versus rook
and white has got three pawns remaining
right so if we start with the move
Knight takes F5 and we provoke white
into trading queens and we do end up
with a situation where I'll put my
knight here I'll put my king here I have
three PS I'm not going to lose the game
but am I going to win the game probably
not no probably not okay uh and is clock
are the clocks a factor Tanya definitely
a factor I mean look at the position kns
on the board clocks are always a factor
they're tricky pieces and right now it
is still blacks move here so Fabby on
the T does he trade on F5 and if he does
take on F5 white can you actually avoid
the queen trade is Knight F5 an option
there I think it is because again your
King has no guard and I could break the
PIN I was asking Rook F yeah Knight
takes F5 Knight takes F5 I think it
leads to the same because after Rook f8
Queen C7 check Rook Rook F7 exactly
correct doesn't work at all so you will
have to go KN E3 anyway here so Rook
yeah and I don't I Rook f8 means I don't
have time to move my knight so I will
end up we have a different decision no
end game right now Fabby says he wants
to fight against anisha's exposed King
instead starts with a check but this
also exposes black SK that C2 lined up
yeah I mean that is not the first move
that would have come to my mind uh
leaving this diagonal you know y I think
what he wants is that if you step up
with the King to the G file then maybe
he just comes back with another check on
G6 okay but now the question is isn't it
help aren't you helping me by keeping an
extra pair of knights on the board and
he's played King G2 and the queen comes
back we might be seeing this we might
see Knight G3 now again in a
straight uh yeah he's reaching Knight in
a straight Knight and three pawns versus
The Rook I I'm kind of with you there
Peter I think we're going to see a draw
adding an extra layer of complexity with
a pair of knights
helps I would say yeah and he's gone
right into this ending and Fabby went
into this ending like yeah I'm ready for
this I I'm not sure I would have
embraced I don't think he had any choice
anymore I think uh by playing Queen A6
check keep painting himself into taken
the Knight on F5 and then gone into a
similar end game but without an extra
pair of knights I'm just wondering if
Fabby wanted to check would Anish repeat
with a check King F1 Queen A6 King G2 is
that something that could have played a
role there maybe but uh regardless he is
in this position I'm not going to say
it's a technical position but I do
believe uh Anish has more chances
than Maybe he deserves now having said
that the H Pawn the pawns are isolated
and vulnerable I think it's
still Trends towards the draw right you
probably take the draw against the other
two results obviously against the black
win but also I think Fabby doesn't lose
this but he's going to he's going to
play well and he's going to have a few
unpleasant moments and ideas of 94 check
and maybe you'll end up picking this
Pawn off the board and he we do have by
the way Rook h8 so he had a somewhat
interesting choice there he could have
gone after the H3 Pawn with the King
completely sidelining the king but
keeping the Rook on a much better file
so I don't know which one is stronger
Also let's point out that if Fabby
manages to sacrifice his rook and Knight
for the three Pawns in the position yes
and we get a king we get two knights a
pure end game that is a draw yes that is
correct two knights um we might actually
you know what I'm going to make a
prediction I think we might see
that really or maybe not uh by the way
in my I I probably played 4,000
tournament games I've never had two
nights and a pawn you know you know what
I mean two nights versus a I was about
to ask there was a recent in the
tournament in dorf where I think you
were a commentator I there was a game
there which reached that end game in I
think in our match as well and nobody
had a
clue neither that's right we were alir
and I were we were watching and then
they gave up a draw ER yeah yeah why is
I think it I think it was Yan's game as
well right it was I'm pretty sure Yanka
was on the strongest side of
that I'm not sure myself uh what sorry T
I was just wondering why Faby wasn't
picking it up he eventually does pick up
the pawn on H3 and now Black's King
can't really step back towards the D6
Pawn but the problem is white the this
Black's King is actually really really
active and uh keeping wh's King at Bay
and as you say if I get in a situation
where I can go Rook takes F2 and Knight
takes D6 one gets the feeling they're
going to be simpler ways to draw than
that yeah exactly exactly I don't see
any issues for we might see a repetition
right here we might see a repetition
KING5 King night C4 Knight jumps back
gives a check King comes back that's
that's exactly right Knight C4 check
King King can come back to E4 and again
very very active King active Rook looks
all good he goes to D4 instead Knight to
D King to D4 okay Knight to
D2 do you think if he actually picks up
the pa6 which is unable do you think he
starts playing for a win yes yes yes he
pushes yes I mean if the D6 Pawn is gone
then you're under no danger at all
exactly and now Anish actually set up a
very cute trick he played D7 in this
position and it looks like Rook H7 just
picks it up right but then we go Knight
F3 check okay and then we go Knight G5
next nice Knight G oh my gosh and then
we might get the Rook versus two Rook
King versus two knights end game oh my
goodness Knight G5 that's very nice
Knight takes G5 allows the queen and
otherwise I'd pick off The Rook which
which is why the Rook went all the way
back to h8 so that so D7 was a oh that's
a cheeky move I mean cheeky you got to
you got to give credit by the way do we
do have a draw I think yes between Jeff
and Wesley Rook h8 Rook on the board
would you rather have the exchange I
would in this position I don't believe
the dwn is going anywhere and I think
the draw is in my hands with black in
the pocket that's what I would feel but
if um if white doesn't if white makes
just a few mistakes maybe you can push
for more with black feels it you got a
little lucky yeah yeah I mean uh it
makes all the difference in the world
put the white King on the C6 square and
we're unsure of ourselves uh but with
the King on
E2 ooh and while players play this on
let's head over to the fua B because
we're getting a big update that F Ali
Raza made a mistake okay so they got
into two seconds did you see that
another move made with just one second
on the clock who had the two seconds Sam
SEI on this side he made it we yesterday
blundered and lost on time up in
exchange up in exchange and queen G5 it
looks like Sam's in the driver's seat on
this one Queen F6 and look at him go
that's two pawns that's two extra pawns
for white opposite color Bishop but it
feels like White's King is actually
going to be safe on the H file uh the
queen supports the bishop he moves the
king away and look at Ali Resa he
reacts he I think Ali Raza when he
played the move Queen B2 in his Mind's
Eye he was going to get to a chance to
play A5 A4 but the check defended the
bishop and and suddenly Sam is also head
on the clock look at this a Down single
single digits and Sam has 34 second and
he continues to shake his head he plays
Queen A1 he wants to get that Queen to
H1 but white just keeps marching with
the King and there is a big threat of
that Bishop going over to F5 and and
starting to threaten mate we've spoken
about the opposite color Bishop complex
the attack against Black's King this is
over this is over this is a and Ali Raza
is just like he's beside himself he
can't believe it no and the issue for
him is even if the Queens come off those
end games are also dead lost now because
the pair of fngg Pawns will be enough
for for Sam to win we've been looking at
Bishop F5 but now Bishop A4 just keeping
that Aon and still making the same
threat sorry Peter you were about tell
us no no you you're you're saying
exactly what I wanted to say myself yeah
Bishop
A4 Sam caught that just in time that
he's ready to trade Queens Queen E7
check let's trade queens and uh I will
win with the two connected pass pawns
now and only way to defend the m is to
trade the Queens Ali RZA does it and
this is a this is a sad position for
black I think it's a very comfortable
win yeah there's not not even a single
issue yeah especially with the yeah
especially with the C4 and D5 in other
words when you put your Bishop on on uh
D4 I will play F6 you'll sacrifice your
Bishop but then I have to and we Ali Raz
a my pick he slips down the leaderboard
with that loss let's jump back to the
Fabby game and are we seeing Fabby say
well he won he he he got into this
ending it was three pawns versus Rook a
knight now it's down to one he snapped
up the dewn and this is what we were
talking about is there a scenario where
Fabby suddenly starts becoming ambitious
yes yes and have we arrived there yes we
have uh and again because the presence
of the knights
especially gives now uh Advantage for
Faby if you're playing for a win
obviously the game should still be a
drawn but uh I would prefer the exchange
I completely agree with you on that yes
and I think it comes down to that cheeky
move that we were talking about D7 which
was such a nice trick to put but it also
made the dwn more vulnerable which
eventually Fabby went on to pick up and
we just seen a move Knight B4 now that
looks a little off-putting because what
is the ah this Knight is coming to both
I I was about to say I can go check and
that puts the kabash on Knight C6 it
doesn't put the kabash on Knight C2
so he does threaten both Knight C6 and
Knight C2 and the King unning himself is
about to advance yes King E5 so if one
pair of knights gets traded off for
example a move like Knight C6 that's
draw on the spot and even without the F
Pawn that's a draw yes that's correct so
if Fabby is ambitious he has to keep the
knights on the board now that's correct
Devils have turned we were talking about
family no question I you don't win these
but percentage
wise there's no harm in trying for at
least a while but it's very very
difficult to see how he makes any
progress because I think kenish is doing
the right thing not breaking the
coordination he has currently
established and um it's just yeah the
king just goes forward now yeah F6 G5
closer to the pawn uh connecting all of
his all of his pieces very very
comfortably G5 is a very nice Square for
this King I think Knight to D5 check
King to G5 as you say I see Knight F6
check as being a threat if I'm white I
want to trade the pair of nights CU then
I feel and you can do it now you can do
it so aw I will uh take that opportunity
with Glee is he going to go Rook f8 Rook
F5 pretty sure he will yeah and it
happens very nice professionally done
professionally done but what a victory
for Ray Robson we are singing his
Praises time
that was an amazing game that he just he
just took nepo twice Challenger right
out yeah and he nearly lost the game at
the same time he was this close to
losing this was the the moment right
here it comes down look at the clock 3
seconds and just now he makes the move
he's reached for it and he press and and
Yan looked at that clock Yan knew that
11 seconds and he's like
you so yes you you person you person you
person uh none of his direct competitors
won in this round so that actually
establishes a a very nice buffer he's
he's a full game ahead of uh of his he's
going tie for first regardless of the
insured ured a tie for first and if he
draws his last game he wins the rapid Y
and goes into goes into here our
standings a very happy man here we are
he actually has a twoo lead which means
that he at least dies for first
regardless as you said Peter regardless
of what happens in the final run and for
that to happen either Maxim andish Oram
have to win their game and this is where
we stand rare option on the brink of one
of the biggest victories of his chess
careers no question can he get the TK
done well we're going to find out for
our third and final round and in the
meanwhile as we go on break uh we asked
the players what they thought about uh
the time controls and these were their
answers we'll see you on the other side
of the
[Music]
break Grand chor has different time
controls rapid bleit and Classics how do
you adjust your playing style or
strategy depending on the time control
yeah it's very different going from one
time control to the other I think I I
mean I just got back from my love man so
switching from classical to Rapid might
be tricky so I think it's important to
play some training games to sort of
adjust to that and then yeah sort of go
from there uh so yeah I really enjoy
playing rapid and Blitz it's much
shorter than classical and lot less
stressful usually you have more fun
playing I think the main difference is
when there's less time on a clock you
can take more risks because the opponent
doesn't have much time to punish you so
uh I think that's basically how most
people play they play a lot more
aggressive more tactical games than
usual and that's probably what I'll try
to do as well yeah by now I'm used uh to
this mix of time control so you know I
try to know what I do best anyway play
fast and put pressure so of course
that's obviously easier busing rapid and
in Blitz some I've been struggling in
the Blitz in the last few tournaments
I've played I've been doing better in
the rapid um that didn't used to be the
case uh but I prepared specifically for
for the bed as well um because I feel
this uh first tournament will be
important I like the format because you
play all kind of Chess so and adjusting
to it is kind of easy because the
tournaments are a bit look like longer
like princess B is in June one is in
July so you can just slowly but um in
general I'm big fan of the format you
play all kind of Chess and you will see
who's the best at the end yeah this is
this is a definitely a challenge to do
uh not not only for the players I think
it's fun to try some different things
but also probably for the people
watching it's interesting to see some
Blitz and some some rapid and uh because
they all have their own peculiarities so
um and we see some guys who are more uh
let's say more motivated for some time
controler for others because they enjoy
it more so it it'll definitely be
interesting to see yeah I mean takes a
while to get used to it definitely I
think it's a very different game between
speed chess and classical I guess as I
heard from another play player you just
got to keep improving on chest you know
try to play your own game try to play
better and what you turn in glassical
will hopefully move itself to Rapid and
blit yeah I'm very bad at adjusting my
style usually I'm always work one step
behind so after I finish the rapid
tournament I'm like I figure out how to
play the rapid and then it's already
Blitz and I'm too slow and then I'm like
just in the mood for the Blitz and then
comes the classical and I'm kind of uh
too fast again so I'm always a step
behind but I'll I'll try I think really
you know this sort of adjustment works
at all it's just about your your
condition if it's good is good if it's
not then then Alice well for me here
it's just rapid and Blitz so I guess I
don't have to adjust that much although
there's still some adjustment between
rapid and Blitz I think for me Blitz is
easier because I play Blitz way more
often even just casually rapid is
difficult I think uh somehow it's in
between classic and Blitz and those are
the two that I play more common
so for me it's difficult to adjust so I
think the only way is to just uh play
more games and practice more so lately I
have been practicing this quite a bit I
play some title Tuesdays something
online um rapbit I have not been playing
that much U mainly J chesto event and
also in bill in July this year I play
some rabbit there and as well as World
up but um I'm very excited to see how I
would do because I haven't play such a
strong uh tournament in Rapid and Bliss
for a long
[Music]
time the 2023 Grand chess tour reaches
its epic inclusion with its fifth world
class event the 2023 sinkfield cup it's
back to classical chess with Front
Runners settling in for the final push
to the Finish Line however two of
America's Finest stand in their way
joining the frey as wild cards who will
try to cash in on the opportunity while
making things as difficult as possible
for hopeful tour players who can win the
illustrious cup and will it be enough
for them to emerge as the 2023 Grand
chess tour Champion follow the St Louis
chess clubs twitch and YouTube channels
to tune in to live coverage of the 2023
sinkfield cup November 21st to December
1st to find
out
hello I'm women's Grand Master V to
janova I will be creating content for
Grand chest store follow us on social
media and catch more behind the scenes
content the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best best players become a
member and enjoy perks such as free
classes and lectures weekly tournaments
and so much more visit St lisess
club.org to claim your membership
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Lewis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy for more
information on current exhibits please
visit World Chess h.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chest sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy the St Louis
chess club Scholastic program brings the
educational value of Chess to kids and
schools across the St Louis area active
in over 100 schools throughout the St
Louis city and county the St Louis chess
club has been able to reach over 85,000
students in both in school and at after
school programs we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
education hello I'm women's grandmas R
to janua I will take you behind the
scenes of the grand chest store follow
us on social media and don't miss out on
players interviews and more content from
the playing
Hall the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States and is among the best in the
world thanks to co-founders Dr jeie
Karen singfield and Rex sinkfield the St
Louis chess club is a nonprofit
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the US
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sinkfield cup
Ken cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over
2,000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
because become a member and enjoy perks
such as free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit St Louis chess club.org
to claim your membership
[Music]
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game
landmarked by the world's largest chess
piece sitting outside our front door the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy including various
exhibitions monthly concerts and much
more whether you are a beginner or a
professional there is something for
everyone to learn here at the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy free admission
to our rotating exhibitions in our
Galleries and sign up for chess events
familyfriendly programming and art
classes and don't forget to stop by our
award-winning gift shop Q Boutique and
Shop a wide selection of Chess related
merchandise for more information on
current exhibits please visit World
Chess h.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the worldclass St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on Art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to
[Music]
enjoy the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 Schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85,000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program and the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grandmaster
verua niobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improve Rel relationships between atrisk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since
2019 the St Louis chess club has also
created a chess merit badge for the
scouts BSA quickly becoming one of the
most popular badges with more than
250,000 Scouts earning the badge since
2011 students of chess can also pick up
a copy of read and WR chess thanks to
Club co-founder Dr jeie keny field
anyone can learn how to understand chess
notation in no time we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
[Music]
seducation fasten your seat belts and
get ready it all comes down to this
final ninth round of the St Louis rapid
can Ray Robson do it can he join the
likes of Hikaru Nakamura leavon Aron and
Magnus Caron alza who have all won a
rapid in the grand Chester that's a p
moment for Ray
Robson but let's take a look at the
standings uh that
Tanya wow I'm just looking at that amaz
stuff he has 11 points on the leader
board one round to go in many ways he's
unsurpassable uh as we can see least
tied for first Maxim vagra Anish G Li a
pack of wolves at nine points and then
we've got Fabby and Sam with eight but
it's all eyes on Ray Robson big
turnaround man that game that Sam seev
on won because it looked like Ali Raza
was the one enjoying matters tell us
about the pairings for this the ninth
and final uh round this is the final
round and Wesley saw struggling in the
event he plays against the tournament
leaders is this a dream pairing for Ray
Robson in the the last round Peter I
would say so because I think Wesley will
be thinking about tomorrow thinking
about restarting from the blitz exactly
rapid clearly has not gone well for him
at all and he generally doesn't play
spoiler all that well I think he is very
content with just ping his thought
thoughts and his hopes on on the blitz
event I'm looking at nepo versus Liam
perua giri and mvl Sean as a big fight
for the second third fourth places as we
get ready and the clocks have started 1
E2 E4 very disconsolate looking W that
did you notice the head shake on move
one I mean it's a bit early in I just
played E2 E4 and I'm not happy with my
decision like what I think right now
Wesley is not happy with a lot of
decisions it has been a tournament that
he wants to put behind him and as Peter
said move on look ahead at the blitz but
for Ray Robson it all comes down to this
one he is uh it's the game of a very
important game of his chess career and
he starts with the Berlin let's point
out that he only needs a draw if this
game ends in a draw Robson wins the
rapid absolutely and these two for those
of you who don't know have a wonderful
history uh between them they were both
Webster University alumni and even more
than that they were roommates so I said
what do you guys do they said well we
don't really go to school we we really
only play Blitz like 14 hours a day
against they know each other really well
very well very very I'm just thinking
right Wesley has had a dismal tournament
so far it's something he wants to forget
R Robson needs only a draw to become
champion of the rapid right what are the
chances of this one ending in a quick
draw and no draw off first thank God for
that no no no in terms of finding a
variation that Ting and draw pretty high
again because Wesley is the one with the
white pieces and he probably wants to
force it now having said that there is a
danger that you become too complacent
that you're thinking to yourself I'm Ray
Robson I know my opponent is having a
bad tourament probably wants to get past
it uh and you don't give Wesley a game
Peter that he's going to be interested
in playing right I think uh that was my
thinking originally but then I I saw how
Wesley reacted to the proposed Berlin
right and I have a feeling he does want
to SP race tournament if possible
because uh the way normally you Castle
not have a game the way not to have a
game here would be to Castle play Rook
E1 something that Wesley has done a
bunch of times in his life and we don't
even talking about the queen queen D4
Queen E4 play this play a completely
risk fre position which you probably
won't win either exactly instead of
which he played D3 uh took on C6 and
also played Bishop G5 here which is one
of the more which is one of the more
fashionable ways of treating this
position and one of the more I think
icious ways of treating this position so
uh looks like Wesley actually wants to
to win a game of chess which is very
welcome developments for everybody apart
from Ray maybe Ray Robson and again big
fights for second place Sam Sean boy
talk about roller coaster right that
he's been having he's essaying um this
very well at one time this became a very
topical line in the open
rui and it was I I worked with Victor
kcho he'd liked to play the open ruy and
we looked at this positions at many many
hours and I really just felt out of my
depth I just didn't understand them
Peter sorry before we Deep dive I have
to I have to ask the burning question
are you team Royal Lopez or team
Spanish uh ruy Lopez I generally all my
life it has been Spanish but I'm kind of
teaching myself to switch between them
at will for no particular you it's
Spanish for me but let's get into the
position now you didn't read the 1500s
uh ruy
Lopez book uh also I we used to call it
the Spanish
torture that was that was a very popular
way of very opt as well because the
opening does feel like that so is it the
Italian or is it the That's Italian is A
Jero piano it's a jerko piano for you
what about you Peter Italian Italian or
Jano Italian Italian all the way what's
wrong with you people about this
particular line uh again it was very
topical at one time this is very very
Central and there's a lot of incredibly
sharp variations here uh I've never
really looked at it properly uh for the
amount of time required to get a handle
on it but I remember we played a match
against aeran in the European Team
Championship in 2015 and I was playing
against Shak M on board one and the team
of seconds for the Russian team gave me
a file and said okay you can do this and
if he remembers everything it will be a
draw he had just no problem whatsoever
remembering remembering everything
because Shah actually did put in the
hours to uh
to get very acquainted with the material
uh it gets very very sharp very often
because uh White often wants to play G2
G4 Force the bishop to G6 we can even
start showing the ideas here it's not a
good move maybe in this position
immediately but it's a move you can you
can make very often with this specific
idea of following it up with Bishop A2
and breaking everything open with5 B6
this of course needs to be fine-tuned if
you play G4 straight away here it might
be possible for black to take on G4
which is something that you need to of
course to keep an eye on right so often
they they start by playing Bishop F4 but
as you can see G4 is statistically the
main move in this position with white
enjoying slightly the better over it but
83% of the games end in a draw wow uh
and this is a very very uh topical very
Theory heavy line very interesting and
quite the fight that you want as well
for maxim Vash currently tied for second
at nine points so it's going to be a fun
middle game another player who is
currently a tied for second Le Wang Liam
okay and uh that's an opening that's got
my attention and I know you're going to
like this one because how did we get
here why did we get here what is
happening exactly so uh this fov at one
moment became a collag
and this has always been a
Kalashnikov there was never a at any
point but then this is like um the
Iranian players's uh name Rook
B8
uh yes thank you uh he likes to play
Rook B8 Hikaru played this in a US
championship game and Peter please I
don't really know very much about this
you've already already informed me of
some things I wasn't aware of but one
thing I I will say is that it seems like
it's uh Liam's choice to go into this
line uh but Yan so far hasn't really
gotten below 25 minutes yet so he he
clearly has some idea or perhaps he is
so tilted by the game he just lost to
Ray Robson which is a danger which which
has been known to happen that he just
trust his hand and he has one of the
best uh instincts in the game so Yan
just trusting his instincts is very
often an incredibly strong player so uh
cannot be discount discounted either
Knight E2 Rook C8 hitting the Knight on
C4 so Knight takes D4 Rook takes C4
Knight takes E6 Rook takes E4 this looks
like a very strange position in which
both the Knight on E6 and the on e4 look
like they could look they could get lost
at any moment D5 is a threat Queen D5
definitely I guess we go Queen maybe E7
and if you play Queen D5 I do have
Knight F6 with a Tempo which is maybe a
very important resource and this
immediately starts looking a lot more
harmonious for black exactly so maybe we
start by playing something like B3 but
obviously it's not a an oil painting of
a move but black still needs to decide
what to do with this Knight on D4 which
is currently hanging and the question
becomes can we play
B5 you can play may try playing B5
Knight takes D4 B takes C4 and if Knight
D6 once again we can try pretending that
the Knight doesn't come back and
honestly maybe it doesn't come back it
doesn't come back it's very possible it
doesn't come back you can play have
Queen G4 and Knight G and queen oh
Knight G7 do king7 let's show that
that's a very beautiful beautiful spot
Knight G7 looks very very clever hitting
the Rook on C8 and giving a check but
unfortunately for white this move
protects everything and the KN on G7 is
lost point is trying to get clever with
the Peter yeah I know it doesn't work
you you can try Queen H3 and currently
the Knight is still alive but this looks
like a very unclear position which could
could very easily be very good for black
exactly and uh Tanya how do these
players match up in their head let's
take a look and well we haven't played
each other that much but uh that's a
total of 13 games if I got the math
right and complete Domination by y pishi
with seven wins only one loss to Liam
and five draws so psychologically a big
upper hand for Yan and I think think we
did see the move B he played B3 and I
also briefly checked what the engine was
saying we we got the M we got the first
line correct this entire line ending
with Queen H3 apparently is correct wow
the Knight stays alive and the engine
suggests you can just play King F7 King
G7 and this is somehow okayish for black
despite being a pawn down because there
is some positional compensation I
suppose it's not immediately obvious to
me exactly why black has positional
compensation here but maybe the threat
is to play let's say we Castle right
black can play H6 and if you go back now
now you're trapped now you will no
longer have squares so the Knight has to
drop back and black perhaps picks up on
e4 and says yes my king is a bit soft
but I have won the pawn back I will drop
the Knight back to F6 and have a
playable position so B3 is critical has
already been played and now the question
is how well does Liam know know this
stuff clearly a little less than Yan
given their clock situation but already
a really interesting uh moment on the
board and we see moves coming in have uh
B5 Knight takes D4 and they are to be
honest on 22 minutes I would suggest
Liam is just remembering there's no way
you do these things this quickly if you
have if you've never seen them before
point exactly I think he is trying to
remember what the files say so will he
take on E6 here while the m has a thing
should we continue absolutely let's do
it sorry I'm going to apologize while
Yan has a think how to play let's
continue with our tour of the positions
that we have now there's another player
who's fighting for a third third place
di fighting for the second place died
for a second and uh that is the board of
Anish giri Al fuja he just drew a well I
want to say a fascinating game with
Fabiano that did seem to have back and
forth moments but it did feel like Anish
was really the one pressing now this
looks like a Queen's Gambit tarash which
it in fact is and it was really I want
to say Sasha uh grishuk that made this
Mo C5 C4 popular and I at one time my
predecessors looked at that and said
garbage but he brought hang on a second
I'm just trying this is a tus with an
extra tempo for Black by the way because
we just assumed it was Aus but let's
show actually how they got here because
it began as a as a REI with Knight F3
and C4 right and then in this position
where this is a very important current
position in opening Theory where after
castles castles white is at a Crossroads
because you can obviously go D2 D4 and
play Absolut Mainline Catan people have
also been trying to play Queen C2 here
and the position after Queen C2 D4 in
particular is now very very topical
there's a lot of top level games
starting from here and this move D2 D3
which is uh what ala fuja ended up
playing against Anish is also sort of
becoming uh an option for white it's
clearly not the most ambitious option in
the world because black can just develop
normally and we've played D3 instead of
D4 but it lets you get a game but what
uh ala did afterwards is very very
surprising to me because he met C5 with
the immediate cd5 E5 and D4 so it's a
Tempo down it's just a full full
fullblown Tempo down tares saying tares
is just such a bad opening I'm going to
give you two moves in a row here this
should not lead to particularly good
outcomes right because normally in this
position white would be playing Bishop
G5 instead I need started by playing H6
ala played Bishop B3 C4 Knight
E5 uh Bishop B4 followed black is
obviously fighting to preserve the the
pawn on D5 safe uh Queen A4 A5 Queen B5
Knight A7 Queen A4 and Bishop F5 this
has gone poorly for white wow uh engine
already prefers this for black
and uh hang on a second and uh it's just
a very unpleasant position B7 B5 is
coming in as you can see two more moves
have happened since uh A3 was met by
Bishop B7 Anish not even willing to take
on C3 and play B5 immediately he
preserves the dark Square Bishop H3 Rook
B8 B7 B5 coming next move if you try to
stop it physically by playing Knight B5
black can play Queen E8 for instance and
force you to go back and then you you
have a pleasant choice of many things
right uh so ala I think is also still
slightly struggling with the with how
his game against Sam ended because we we
switched to his game against Sam
immediately after a completely
inexplicable decision by him he uh had a
very very safe draw with the most
obvious move in the world and instead he
just gave up the entire King side and
lost yeah and it it wasn't even that
clear what he missed to be honest it
just seemed like a very very strange
decision it did and we saw Sam savian
taking the point against ala are
currently struggling against Anish
meanwhile Sam savan against Maxim vasher
lra the position has
exploded and I think we have to rush
over to that board again a really
important fight with Maxim vagra
currently tied for second one of the
players who could catch up with Ray
Robson if he wins this but let's start
Let's do an action replay get up to date
because some very critical moments
happened yeah we did see uh the line
that uh Peter mentioned
including G4 getting in Bishop A2 very
ambitiously aiming for E5 E6 but by the
way this Pawn on D3 what's really
confounding about this whole line of
play is you let it exist you don't you
know try well you want to win it the
problem is you never do but you play
around it and this is the threat E5 E6
Rook f8 this smacks of preparation Peter
and Rook f8 is still reasonably well
known E6 Queen d8 uh ba Rook
A5 they went through a moment where uh
it was still a new territory because
normally people include ba A5 Rook A5
first but now we're returning to a
position which has been discussed many a
Time some very important correspondence
games clearly there's also a game
between Anam muuk and dinar sakasa
reaching this position but Bishop G3 is
apparently a novelty people have been
taking on F7 here in instead uh and the
engine disagrees with it the engine says
the engine says F7 F5 here is very
strong just removing the possibility of
taking on F7 I don't know how obvious
this this is because leaving white with
this passer on E6 is maybe a bit
counterintuitive but you you're trying
to block out the bishop completely by
playing A5 F4 clear and but it's so
confounding to me Peter there's a prot
there's a pass Pawn on D3 a black pass
pawn and there's a there's a White Pass
Pawn on E6 and you just ignore what
you're doing but I love the idea of F5
F4 that is very very attrative F5 does
look very attractive here I think the
problem is just spotting that the move
exists I think your brain kind of
refuses to entertain the idea of leaving
this bishop on A2 and the King on G8 on
the same diagonal and the move uh Sam
saian has actually played is very easily
explained exactly by that because you
know your plan is to play King h8 and
eventually take on E6 so he's continuing
with the classical approach but F5 I
think was a reasonably big opportunity
Miss there by Sam I with my limited
knowledge of black in this position but
I have a little bit I would also be very
tempted to think about sacrifices on A2
Rook takes Bishop give up that exchange
and capture that pawn on E6 I want to
open up and I'm sure the computer is
just going to laugh at this and say no
completely play doesn't laugh I love the
queen on let me laugh the computer likes
it
so this is something I think that white
also has to watch out in these positions
even after King to h8 Rook takes Bishop
is always in the air unless white takes
an immediate decision with taking on F7
I agree but I I love this but and by the
way I mean again after move King h8 what
is white aspiring for Peter it's not
obvious to me he did capture by the way
on F7 and we actually back in heavy
heavy correspondence territory there's a
lot of very high rated correspondence
game uh reaching this position all from
the last five years I'm assuming if I
play Bishop F7 Bishop F7 Rook A1 cuz I
want to get your queen over there to A1
six games reach this position all six
black played H7 H6 of course of course
yeah because because apparently white
has no way to improve and you can spend
an additional Tempo on something and
then you will be taking on F7 at some at
some point in the future it's useful
yeah let's say Bishop B6 we will trade
on A1 okay and we will get the same
position but we've played H7 H6 which
should generally be a beneficial thing
for us right and the pawn on D3 is still
alive yes but that is usually the case
in these openings right like you said I
think yasa you put it really well that
white just ends up playing around this
Pawn any end game where pieces heavy
pieces are traded off that pawn on D3
which actually looks really nice is a
glaring weakness uh and often just drops
off in an end game so for black it's
really important to keep the tension and
keep the counter play uh in the middle
game to try to look for dynamic
opportunities and we will keep keep an
eye out on that uh is it time to check
in with our tournament leader yes
absolutely Wesley so and Ray robs that
is a very on Berlin looking like Berlin
to me on Berlin say that Berlin to me
not sure but you you know what I mean I
know what you mean this is a very sharp
position the Paul on E5 is hanging
there's no I mean you can play Bishop D6
but I don't think you particularly want
to it's no then you start to worry that
D3 D4 at a certain moment might be from
a tactical Viewpoint you can currently
play long castles because that also
creates this x-ray along the D file
meaning that we will have Bishop takes
E4 here got uh so white most likely will
reply to Long Castles by playing Queen
E2 and now you do have to think about
protecting the pawn on E5 uh I think the
suggestion would be to maybe include
Bishop before check okay to ask white to
either lose the right to Castle or to
play C2 C3 which softens up a little bit
of the the central structure and then
drop back to D6 and we get a kind of a
weird position where black is quite
healthy and I would be maybe even
preferring black if the bishop wasn't on
G6 right this bishop on G6 needs C King
B8 Bishop C8 you pick black here maybe
even right I remember the game ofo and
Ali Raza right I mean very very uh from
round one where where Fabby had Castle
kingside got himself into trouble now in
these positions though Peter don't you
say I'm white I'm very clever
I'm going to play A4 B4 B5 and not tell
you where I'm putting my king we just
play King F1 and keep it there yeah
right right be a little C very very
possibly yeah I think if we're going
this side we're actually not castling I
think we are legitimately going King
ofan King G2 because that M makes us
much better prepared for the eventual H6
H5 The Rook is already on H1 so we are
much readier for the eventual potential
opening of the h f but I think it's very
possible just to keep it on and not
touch it for now right you can also Play
Bishop G3 provoke Knight D7 maybe play
Knight H4 put it on F5 also seems very
play I'm liking Wesley's position here
uh Ray Robson for those of you joining
us late shame on you he's leading the
tournament but how did he get here he
did it by being undefeated uh he did it
in style yes and this has been his
performance so far let's remind everyone
it's two points for a win a point for a
draw and zero for a loss and look at
that score line you see no zeros at all
he is undefeated and that's quite the
achievement with the field of players
that we have here the only player to
have won three games yeah yes it looked
quiet because the two draws and win and
two draws and Liam was doing so
incredibly well but it was that sixth
round that really catapulted him Liam
Liam uh well I don't want to say
collapsed Fabby actually played a very
very nice game but Fabby won against
Liam knocked him out of first Ray said
excuse me guys I want to win a second
game and here we are and how many people
at the start of this tournament would
have bet Andre winning this with this
field uh not ourselves not ourselves we
had our picks and we went with some very
safe options I thought I went with a
safe one we're talking about the best
players in the world that's right and
Ray Robson just on quite the streak
right now he has played well I figured
it out it's the most UN Berlin Berlin
that I have seen with a position that
feels like it should be fine for Ray
with the black pieces but were you ready
for Peter's
readier he's reier I'm reest now with
all of that but we have another board
that has been set up and in the me in
the meantime what happened I I was I
think originally on my assessment was
correct but this was a very very
important detail that I missed the the
availability of the move2 before here
for
alza made his position very playable
takes takes kn6 happened he played G3 G4
here and Anish seems to have
miscalculated quite badly because just
dropping the bishop back here was
completely playable but he chose to play
Bishop takes B4 thinking that he's
attacking the Knight on C3 if white
takes the Rook will reprotect the the
bishop is probably missing the move
Knight A2 I would suspect because after
KN A2 suddenly your Bishop is hanging
this bishop is also hanging uh you can
play Rook a
and this results in a long line starting
with Knight C6 Rook A4 we take on d8 the
bishop probably drops back now we can
take on B7 and you can pin the Knight on
A2 moment and force white to take on B4
so your position is not entirely lost
because you do have this passer on C4
which needs to be controlled somehow but
white does have two light pieces for a
rook not even a rook on a pawn just a
pure two white two light pieces Against
The Rook which should give white a
reasonably save safe Advantage by the
way that was a very forcing line Peter
was like capture capture capture capture
and better takes stes that's the one
that's the one takes takes so once again
Rook A8 and is there any seems to be the
absolute absolutely the only move
because otherwise I think you lose a
full piece I don't really see any other
options the the the crazy part is when
you suggested Rook A8 Knight C6 wasn't
in my vision I feel the vision Rook A8
Queen
B5 if Queen B5 then pieces are hanging
everywhere
somehow black gets to play Bishop D6 now
the point I guess is we cannot include
the intermediate Knight takes C6 because
B takes C6 the tempo hits the the queen
on B5 so you have to go g takes F5 and
now after Knight E5 and Bishop E5 guess
what BL gets a playable position because
this this is a very unpleasant pin but
Bishop D6 is not the easiest resource to
spot there you will have to though but
you might not have any choices yeah if
if that's the only move that doesn't
lose you the game on the spot you will
you will have have to eventually arrive
at it so once again Knight takes
C6 Rook takes A4 Knight takes d8 Bishop
had to drop very importantly if you take
on before here seemingly improving your
situation dramatically the Knight is
trapped on8 that protects the pawn on B7
and the Knight and the Knight is trapped
and this is suddenly very good for black
sorry continue right here Rook A8 I I
mean I'm still trying to get my mind
around this very unusual position I'm
not sure I I guess it's just the Knight
is trapped yeah unpinning unpinning that
Knight will be so difficult and the C
Pawn is already so far down the board it
will be on C2 protected by the bishop on
D6 as well are we too slow with Rook D6
Rook Rook B6 Rook
D6 maybe not no no I think C3 is really
nice but I'm just wondering is it too
slow to actually try and win once your
Rook gets to D6 then I go Knight takes I
might be able to stop it though oh
that's that's uh mean I might be able to
stop it and put the bishop Pawn C7
actually IED
a really nice
idea let's he wanted to trick me let's
do that I would never Tanya not not on
air not on never you didn't just do that
not on a million years and how did they
match up really interesting middle game
lots of tactics and this is their
head-to-head so far in Rapid chest 25
games totally and it is in total and it
is Ali Resa fuja who leads with 10 wins
to five losses is the world Blitz number
one a good lifetime score so far no
question about it two to one advantage
for sure and what else do you have for
us this is the game we haven't spoken
about at all this is a game between
Fabiano Karana and Jeffrey Shong in
which Fabby has a a pleasant uh a
pleasant little ledge here with the
white pieces from what was uh another
Joko piano that I guess is a Hungarian
yeah because he he he decided not to
give uh uh Jeffrey an option to play the
Petro and then uh in the in the bishop
opening after Knight F6 D3 Knight C6
Knight F3 actually it was an Italian to
begin with and then the bishop got
dropped back Bishop G5 is a very very
fashionable way of playing the Italian
right now inviting crazy complications
where black chooses to play G5 and
things really blow up but Bishop B7 is a
very possible response to these types of
positions trying to keep things under
control and then a lot of shuffling I
I'm not personally a huge fan of this
particular change of structure but a lot
of people do it do it willingly and from
there we got to hear where white has a
pleasant Central Central presence uh
some space some space gained on the King
on the queen side safer King should be a
pleasant Edge for white it's a long
fight this one and like you said a rich
position we will come back to this but
I'm I'm just caught up with what I'm
seeing in front of me and I think we
have to rush to this board NE
playing against leang when we left it
what on Earth is going on exactly we saw
a rook uh sorry saw Knight what knight7
we spoke about this Knight was on F6
shees B3 she takes B3 was played instead
of Knight F6 Knight F6 let's talk a
little bit about that so we left it last
we were looking at Knight F6 correct
where Knight G7 is impossible because
now black steps up with the King and
notice how The Rook on h8 connects with
the Rook on C8 and white ends up losing
the Knight It's Magic It's Magic but it
happens right H instead he didn't play
Knight F6 which was a Tempo against the
queen Liam just included the move C
takes B3 and this looks like uh an
opportunity for nepo to pounce which he
did he played Knight G7 check Peter King
went to d8 check and you got
in no castling yeah the point of n G7
and then coming back to E6 which seems
just to be a waste of everybody's time
is no no no no castling yeah now that
the King has moved black will not be
able to Castle and then a very precise
move Knight G5 here attacking The Rook
on C8 before black can get Knight F6 in
pretty much forcing Rook takes C2 and
then this reasonably forcing sequence uh
White finally gets to Castle black
finally gets to drive the Knight on G5
away uh and now after Knight F6 Queen C2
Queen C8 after all that sacrif should
probably survive I suppose but it's it's
obviously it's obviously much more
pleasant to play with white with the
King complete safety against the king in
the center but the material is very
limited mhm uh black doesn't really have
that many weaknesses you will play
something like Queen C6 here right you
will try to play Rook C8 or Rook B8 the
king will go to F7 G7 yes it's clearly
white for choice but the advantage is
not massive not
massive yeah I mean it's a really it's a
fascinating sequence of moves and as
usual the computer says both sides are
fine with precise play but C takes B3
calculating his way through impressive
stuff by Liam Queen A3 on the board as
Knight takes E5 is in can we agree that
we would want to be white here even if
it's level again Black's King is more
exposed the D6 weakness the A6 weakness
you're getting to it faster you want
your Rook into the game and of course
someday if your knight ever lands on D5
that will be over that's the big dream
it's not getting there black has a
knight on F6 but white just seems to
have the right outposts as well well
it's this King safety issue right uh
you're eyeballing Knight takes E5 as a
as a very very direct threat you're
looking Rook you're looking at Rook C1
so it's a double threat Peter it's it's
not you're right it's not losing it's
not losing but it's not pleasant either
yeah having missed Queen A3 I was much
more optimistic about Black's chances
and having having now seen find this
move I suspect it's still holdable with
precise play I the underlying problems
of winning this because of limited
material it's still going to be very
difficult to convert but Queen A3 is
just a a nightmare move to face in a
practical game because suddenly there
are all these threats that you need to
exactly get your head around uh I just
wanted to share an Insight here in the
game of Fabby for a moment H uh when you
play the move E4 E5 and your opponent
plays Bishop C4 and this is a this is
one of the greatest uh theoretically
prepared players in the world Fabiano
Karana and Fabby is saying I don't have
a good answer for your Russian defense I
don't when you play the Petro so I'm
going to play Bishop C4 so that when you
play the Petro I play D3 so it's like
I'm playing The Bishop's opening right
and it's a moral victory for Jeffrey so
I was playing against Tony miles and
Tony miles on move one was playing B6
against everything E4 D4 play whatever
you want he's going to play B6 I play G3
Tony loudly leans across the board and
says I love these moral
victories he said that during the game
yes like and very loudly everybody in
the T I love it so did you feel like you
had the moral Victory you no more are
you going to go the moral victory so I'm
waiting for Jeffrey to lean across the
board and say to favato I love these
moral victories the fact that you don't
allow my pet means you're scared of it
so uh where's the action let's let's
take a look at some of the boards uh the
the open Spanish Pawn on D3 is still
alive still there I'm beginning to think
maybe black is a bit better because I
don't see any attack on the king side
and the pawn is kind of annoying right
right but maybe H4 G5 will start
happening at some point and maybe it's
not that the king yeah because White
Steel enjoys the much much safer King
here uh in the game between uh Wesley
and Ray we are in for a long grindy game
I think because they they both castled
Queen side and uh it seems like nothing
much will be happening in the immediate
future let's check in on on this Rook A8
has been found by an giri out of
necessity
and now I think ala is trying to figure
out if Knight takes C6 is the best he
has or if perhaps something
like so I think we will we will now very
very quickly get to the position we were
discussing after 8 takes takes takes
yeah Anish will play Bishop somewhere I
don't know if there is any argument for
playing something like Bishop C2 instead
of Bishop G6 I suspect not I think G6 is
just a very good Square exactly uh so
I'm expecting Bishop G6 to happen and
then we will arrive at that position
with the pieces Against The Rook I will
remind our viewers how we're likely to
get there right so this I get two pieces
two light pieces for The Rook of course
and something like Knight C5 forance but
you do have a pass Pawn Yeah a pass a c
Pawn that's if you move this Pawn from
C4 to E6 this is basically winning for
white but because of how strong this
Pawn is and also how slightly awkward
like both of our Bishops are currently
not the best the most active Bishops in
the world is a scary thought let's go C3
and and can I play Knight D5 Peter one
wins on the sport right oh I can't take
so yeah that's a nice trick that would
be a problem that is that would be a
problem that's
painful uh so yeah not a back rank
Checkmate you see every time day with
the bishop on G right and C3 there's
definitely still technical issues for
white to overcome I I don't know what
the computer eval is but playing this
position looking at it I almost just
feel like I'd want to be black here and
I'm sure maybe computer holds this and I
see it says white has a big Advantage
but it feels like there are a lot of
immediate threats that fuan needs to
deal with Ah that's C3 C3 isn't even the
best move C3 F4 that gets out of the
back rack M and you take on D5 and I'm
threatening F5 um blocking the bishop so
the engine is suggesting uh starting
with Rook F1 Bishop f11 Bishop yeah
getting the important things uh down on
the board first then reacting to F4 I
think pretty much always with Bishop B4
and going from there and an the precise
player that he is of course finds Bishop
to G6 yeah we're we're currently here
and uh whoa oh Rook A8 this is the move
that uh attracted my eye knight takes B4
and Rook A8 now he was
thinking why you demonstrated that Rook
B6 and Rook D6 would be an awful mistake
for black also good I I honestly I
thought this wasn't going to be as good
as the other option and it's maybe
slightly worse but white is still better
I honestly I thought this is just not
going to be better for white at all the
the reason I think white has a trick of
playing Rook to B8 and threatening Rook
takes B7 that is probably one of the
reason because that Knight on d8 looks
very peculiar that's not a not a pattern
of a pin that you see often quite
surviving after C3 though I don't the
engine goes Rook C1 for now and C2
doesn't even play C2 for some reason I'm
I guess it's always a four or five we I
think we just underestimate how strong a
four or five is in all of these
positions once we've secured a blockade
on the C1 Square which is supported by
the bishop only3
remarkable remarkable and by the way uh
just to remind everybody of the obvious
uh today is the end of the Rapids and
it's all about the blitz uh tomorrow and
a Saturday we will have nine rounds of
Blitz each day and yes we will have a
rapid winner today but it's all about
becoming the combined winner of the St
Louis rapid and Blitz and it's going to
be nine rounds tomorrow yes but a total
of 18 rounds which means a total of 18
points at stake for the players exactly
for the blitz is a traditional one point
for the win half and huge update
speaking about points for a win I think
Yan napesi is about to grab some points
in his position because a lot has
happened after the move Queen A3 and a
big move just played absolutely and it
seems like
Liam has lost lost attention perhaps for
a second his position was perfectly
serviceable and then we take it from
Queen A3 what really happened after
Queen I like the move Knight D7 that
Liam played preparing to Tak C5
preparing to meet Rook C1 I suspect we
simply Queen takes C4 because we've
defanged the threat of Rook C7 to a
large degree so that provoked Rook D1
giving black time to play Knight C5 Rook
D5 and here the engine was suggesting
Rook C8 was very strong strong with the
same idea that Liam used in the game but
it wouldn't have allowed the sacrifice
that happened if you play Rook C8 let's
say H3 you can play Queen A4 here which
more or less forces white to abandon the
E4 Pawn because you really you're
actually not going to like that end game
if you trade Queens here no black will
start playing for a win he chose Rook B8
instead he chose Rook B8 instead with
the same idea oops most likely missing
rookie five altogether and it's actually
quite lucky for him that he can continue
the game because he can play something
like K D7 which probably forces white to
enter this end
game uh which is of course still much
better for white but you will have to uh
solve some technical issues Rook A5 for
instance black has the option of playing
Rook B4 and there are decent drawing
chances despite white suddenly being a
full a full Pawn up yeah uh but let's
show what happens if you if you do take
the Rook well now it's Queen and Knight
versus uh King not only this queen and
Knight versus King you also have the
issue of not being able to run in this
direction because that
loses you have to go to the dile either
D7 or d8 probably d8 because allowing
Knight Tak C5 with check is wrong right
and white has the choice of Pawns to win
you can you can even perhaps go after
the king side like I'm I would very much
consider playing with I like that one
this is very safe very safe this one not
so much no no uh so yeah suddenly
problems for for Le and chance for Yan
to finish the rapid on a high after a
very difficult L start which is what you
want going into the blitz to finish on a
high to get that momentum going and
we're also getting an update that us
Fabby might be getting uh the momentum
going in his game the momentum uh Knight
takes F3 Rook E3 we're just uh catching
up with the players uh D5 C5 well half
open C file uh back award Pawn on that
open file let's let's target the pawn
and you're going to bring a third piece
into the
attack I I feel so uh Rook C1 is the
most natural I provoking Bishop d8 feels
right right I mean just let's let's
start here and now the question is do I
want to take the the the one piece I
feel is not earning its keep is the
Knight on F3 transferring the Knight
whether it be to
F5 uh or
well I can't really get to
A5 Peter where where's the where's the
ideal Square for I I was about to did
sort of offer the same discussion to you
because I it feels like the way for us
to improve with white is and bishop4 he
played on our screens yeah Fab clearly
agreeing with us on the topic of which
piece needs to be improved I think he
he's doing the right thing he will play
G3 he has already played G3 he will play
King G2 and H4 perhaps H4 first I think
you start with King G2 right you will
probably include H3 H4 so that you never
have to think about Bishop G5 in this
game right and then you will start
looking for improvements but yeah the
but it comes back to where does the
Knight belong best E3 probably think
yeah so some something like Knight D2 C4
E3 H2
G4 another thing I would suggest is with
black really only having the F file as a
potential source of counterplay
something like playing uh once again you
have to watch out for Bishop G5 but
trading one pair of Rooks along the f
file for white is may be a good idea for
white because I think that completely
removes any possibility of black
developing any inti so we're just going
to make a a series of moves and we're
not really too sure if these are good or
bad but the idea I would consider Rook
three here yeah I would consider Rook
of3 here just to get one pair of Rooks
off the board and then in proceed in
complete safety from that moment on I
know that there will be no counterplay I
see so I mean as opposed to getting your
knight into
um good Waters this is where you think
if you allow yeah currently C7 is
hanging but if you allow black to play
Rook cf8 and then bring the bishop back
to d8 you have to pay attention to the
file and I I would very much like not to
have to think about the king side at all
for the rest of the game which is why
I'm mentioning I think that's a really a
master class moment what and we
interrupt this programming to bring you
the bishop on H7 in the game between
Wesley so and Ray Robson let's head over
to the tournament leader so we can wrap
this up by saying that Fabiano a d seat
in this one yeah and we head over to Ray
Robson having a very well for the lack
of better really ugly Bishop on 87 I
think we can say is that a big Pawn is
that a bishop what's going on are you
dreaming of f five I don't see that
coming anytime soon I I like White's
position remember I remember David
brunstein doing this in a caroan where
he went Bishop F Bishop F5 in a Caro
Bishop went to G6 went to H7 and the guy
went Knight E5 Bishop C4 and he went
Bishop
G8 maybe that is the idea the bishop
will eventually go to G8 and battery up
with the queen and at someday deliver a
Checkmate on A2 as well and but that
said yeah you look at this position and
then instinctively you you you like
white right you're looking at these
potential breaks with F4 D4 at the right
time the Knight on C4 the bishop on G3
attacking E5 for now but how do you make
progress here that's always you're going
to you're going to play for your break
which break are you looking F4 D4 well
if my Rooks were on F1 and I could uh
really gang up uh powerfully on the F7
Pawn sure I play F4 if my Rook is on D1
which it already is I'm in inclined
towards the D4 break and bringing my
Rook to D1 and I remember Grandmaster
from Bulgaria aghy orov and I had such a
position against afgh and I said look at
your Bishop your Bishop on H7 is is ugly
and he looked at me and he said yes sir
how can a bishop ever be
bad this was a man in love with his
Bishop's Peter are you in love with your
Bishop on H7 not particularly I mean
remember I was the one who started kind
of screaming at the screen when I saw it
maybe it's not that bad though uh I
don't mind Bishop C5 because on the
topic of which break you choose against
something like F6 I think I would be
very tempted to start calculating D4
just because of just how many pieces are
stuck on the king side currently and if
we look at a position for instance uh
something like this yeah we drop it back
to G2 we bring the other one to G1 and
there is some hint of a potential attack
against the black king it probably
doesn't come to very much against the
computer but from a human perspective
this looks promising we we have the
double Rooks on the G5 we have a very
nice Bishop on G3 completely safe
structure which will be very very
difficult to challenge so I like this
for white and I like Bishop C5 saying
this particular break I'm not going to
allow you but Wes says you're not
slipping the other one it's on the board
you're not slipping the other one so
I'll go for the other your choice you
know the one thing about chassen I I
feel evaluating positions yes sir and I
don't it was my coach who told me this
that when material is balanced and when
material is level and I think this is
some good advice that and you're trying
to understand who's better think about
who has the pawn braks in the position
the side with more Pawn mobility and the
options to break open the position
usually has that slight Edge the slight
pull in it agreed yeah who's your
coach this was uh this was a training
camp we had for the Olympiad and I think
it was Boris galin who I was about to
say are you talking Boris gin that
sounds like some really
worldly good worldly advice uh Boris
galin and I agree with it you have
you're in a driver seat you're the one
that when you can initiate the action
it's nice to have that option in your
pocket you were about to show us that
game of Ali Raz no I'm looking through
things but I think this is this is the
important game of the round this is the
one that defines whether definitely wins
the tournament or he will have to depend
on other people not winning right and
the engine doesn't really hate it all
that all that much for black suggested
B5 with the King on C8 is not a move you
make easily but I think it's makeable in
particular in connection with trying to
make your pieces play again this break
this break is needed for black it feels
like you can't really play with his
Bishop on H7 out of the game for too
long right so this supposedly is uh is
playable for black I understand human
players probably are going to be
reluctant to do this to their position
because like you D4 D5 right you
suddenly feel like maybe g45 works and
you get mated what actually happens
probably is that you win a couple of
pieces and you
win C6
mission3 you just ignore all4 is also
hanging like everything is hanging but
it's it's it's a scary thought I'm not
sure Ray does this I'm wondering if you
can start with F5 because starting with
F5 and keeping your queen keeping your
queen side safe for the time being is
seemingly more sensible but the engine
was insisting on starting yeah this for
some reason
is bad because yeah I don't know why
this is so good for white but this is
suddenly Queen A5 is a threat I guess ah
and by the way you're threatening maid
on C7 maid if you try if you try to do
the same thing here you just straight up
lose immediately with5 that's a splash
yeah finding finding quin2 here is also
quite a tricky thing to do so but in
some ways you can come to the decision
because you want to S step with the pin
along the E file you want to find a good
Square for the queen to free up your
knight on E3 yeah I I think the issue
there would be just to start calculating
EF5 because EF5 seems to open up your
position to everything it improves the
bishop on H7 uh it also the pin along
the E file becomes so much more
pronounced so uh if you just get to that
position and start looking for moves yes
Queen D2 should probably present itself
but I I honestly I'd much rather maybe
even pass here like a move like I don't
know Rook hf1 here trying to provoke
this and then go in with D4 D5 and go
for mate even this maybe would be as you
can see this actually is strong yeah I
was I was sort of joking this out this
actually is strong yeah and it comes
down to the point about Pawn Mobility
right you go D4 D5 you break open
Black's King the Knight jumps on to D5
how much in trouble is Ray Robson from a
practical perspective in this position
and seems like he he did play
F5 and we have a decision and Wesley
instantly took instantly took twice yeah
which is I think a relief because now
after Bishop touching the one and a half
minute Mark re Robson and the position
is just heating up oh yeah but now after
Bishop takes F5 is a I'm guessing W's
idea is to play Queen H2 here and to try
for similar things but from this side
yeah well you are C7 why is Queen D2
just about to ask yeah the engine says
it's just much better for us that we
like the removal from from the board the
pawns on G4 and F5 just works for black
we were complaining about that Bishop on
87 that's a proper Bishop now that's no
more a big Pawn anymore if if we compare
this position with the position we were
discussing early if black does the same
here there is still this really really
poor Bishop on H7 so this the engine
prefers white here and no longer no
longer really prefers white here
interesting wow these are all very
intricate calculations though F5 Bishop
okay we do have F5 Bishop we're not
we're about to say Bishop takes F5 uh
break
that it's not great but maybe this is
why he hasn't played Bishop takes a five
yet because he's actually but he's
played it now it's on the board he has
played I was curious how do we meet
Queen
H2 after Queen F5 or here no here but
que do you have a threat I want to take
on F5 and7 yeah the the engine actually
goes B5 says I can no longer tolerate
this Knight on C4 because it prevents me
from being comfortable playing B6 so now
if I take on F5 you take on F5 I move my
knight to say D2 now you have Bishop B
we have Bishop B6 with a
reasonably is position you still I think
you you still prefer white here but
actually no because the Knight
immediately gets challenged we have we
have this on the board we do queen H2
played and B5 B5 played R Robson just
doing great things with 30 seconds on 35
seconds on I think we stay here
impressive I think we stay here and
playing a move like B5 kicking that
Knight but pushing Pawns in front of
your king and taking these very big
decisions critical decisions on
seconds I mean it's just been awesome to
watch replay this event yeah no I mean
he's definitely not it's not not just
his great scorer because sometimes you
can have a good score and play poorly
he's played it very very very well this
is his line score
undefeated and he has the games that
he's won
like for example against neppo against
Ali re Ali Raza have been impressive
games three wins the rest of five draws
so far and right now playing with 30
seconds on the clock but making All the
Right Moves rear Robson continues to
impress and it's very often chess
players in time trouble they want to
bail out of positions they want to
decrease the tension on the board you're
looking for trades you're looking for
easier moves easier option hand moves
but it feels like re has this incredible
ability to play the most complex moves
uh to take these big decisions without
hesitation in those moments sometimes
with a second on the clock and by the
way this move B7 B5 that's not an easy
decision because you do weaken uh the
protection around your king but as Peter
was mentioning it's about having Bishop
B6 as a comfy way of defending the pawn
on C7 uh I know we're going to stay on
this game I'm just going to make a quick
game ER at nbl's position very important
one because looks like it's heading for
a draw excellent news uh Fab's position
excellent news for Ray Robson because
Maxim if he wins he can potentially
catch up with Ray precisely uh Fabby uh
enjoying matters a little bit against um
Fabby Fabby has a very pleasant position
for sure against Jeffrey uh fua he had
the two minor pieces and now it looks
even much much better it looks like in
fact Anish is losing no this moment this
there was a a very non-obvious mistake
from from alira which I only am calling
a mistake because I have an engine here
helping me and this apparently is
completely fine for black now because no
yeah you can you can play Knight
D6 uh and The Rook will have to uh
Retreat along the E Rank and then you
play Rook B2 the PA on C2 survived you
have Rook E8 coming in with additional
sources of counterplay and that being
continues being incredibly annoying for
white so the engine just gives straight
up zeros here amazing
nepo uh quickly he's much better against
he's much better got an extra Pawn he's
the one who's pushing and Liam was the
other player who could have caught up
which is again good news for Ray Robson
so let's head back to our absolutely Mar
game indeed wesly so versus Ray Robson
and we do have a trade after Queen H2 B5
D4 or Wesley said okay I don't want to
see your Bishop secured on the B6 Square
so let's tradeing the Knight for the
dark Square Bishop Knight C played the
engine suggests starting with Queen D2
here Queen D2 reestablishing that threat
of Queen A5 which we're quite familiar
with
already which might actually black might
need to play Knight B7 here which is
going to be a very very ugly move to
move a difficult one with 12 seconds
yeah that's not going to be fun I I
would I would be fighting with myself
Tanya trying to play a move like Knight
B7 here but Queen A5 is actually
allowing it is really severe Queen A5
will win the game if it lands on the
board so you will be you you have to
play Knight B7 and then the agent
suggests taking on F5 playing Queen D4
and this looks comfy continuing to
attack all kinds of things every move I
like it's not winning but it definitely
is better for white it's
definitely triple pawns on the sea line
who cares about the extra Pawn that
black
has that could be one of the most
hideous Pawn structures that I've seen
with lovely lovely description hideous I
like it that's that's exactly what it
looks like it was an ugly Bishop this is
a badl looking Pawn structure it's a
hideous Pawn structure you're right uh I
like what uh what Wesley has discovered
here in this position D4 we got moves
coming in takes did he play Queen D2 as
you can see on our screens yeah he's
still thinking he's done to 3 minutes
but Ray is on 12 seconds so it's still
comfortable Queen D2 wasn't obvious for
me I was actually thinking that that
white wanted to play Rook D4 and Rook D1
it's very interesting what you said that
Queen D2 wasn't obvious and I think the
reason we were able to come up with
because we've seen it earlier it's an
idea that exists in the mind and it's so
easy to forget how difficult these moves
that you find on the board and one can
think that you know Wesley saw one of
the greatest players why is he not Queen
D2 it's not an easy move to spot when
you don't have an EV Valar helping you
with variations and when you have't
looked at this idea before and also when
you've played the move Queen H2 and but
he finds it just as we said it wow uh
impressive because you've just played
this7 and did you see the speed and the
way he played it how many seconds did he
have left when he did it got to get an
action replay of Knight B7 he I think he
I think he has 18 now he has 18 he
played it so fast and the Knight almost
went to
A8 it's got a good triple weight to feel
these pieces uh and queen C3 again That
Hideous Pond structure let's just uh
tickle them it's one of those Pond
structures you want to keep tickling but
never grab those ponds because they're
kind of better on the board than off the
board for white right oh look at that
the pieces are falling and has to adjust
it in his opponent's time it's getting
tricky Panic stuff Queen seconds on the
clock a little bit uh tricky the
desirable Rook
D4 defending the bishop hangs The Rook
so I'm assuming we're going to play Rook
F1 I'm I'm sure he's intending Bishop
takes H3 and I'm looking at all kinds of
Queen g7s which would win on the game on
the spot in some positions but Queen E7
still exists so this is this is still
tricky for for West Rook seven in
certain position yeah could I very good
point could I continue with Rook to
maybe
D4 I think Wesley is now struggling with
uh he wants to generally of course you
want to make unexpected moves here
against the person on 12 seconds is a
very much and you know that Ray has
calculated all the most obvious options
here such as Knight takes F5 probably
Rook H F1 has been calculated and he's
looking for something which could be a
surprise but I'm struggling to find
Queen A3 Queen A3 that would be that is
it might lose though because I think I
can take on F4 and go Knight D6 and
prepare the D7 Square for my king it
might not work ah so Bishop F1 will take
on so not allowing any takes of the Pawn
on H3 we do have Knight
takes F5 and now you can't take on on C4
can we can rookie for Queen
C3 we have Queen C3 yeah but I think if
he takes on C4 his problem is Queen E4
not Rook E4 because Queen E4 gets the
Queens off the board
improv no no no no I have no Queen s
here you have Rook E7 Queen yeah I miss
queen f s no no but it's not but Queen
F7 doesn't really help because you got
rook h87 and Rook E7 I can put the queen
on F6 and maybe the Queens don't come
off as long as the Queens stay on the
board I'm
very but I would prefer not to take uh
that pawn again I'm I'm more into the
Rook D4
I
C4 now what Ray did by the way is he
played this move Queen E4 and he kind of
knocked the pieces around a bit there
you go he kind of like hit the bishop he
grabbed and he pressed the clock with
the two
seconds that is not that is not correct
that is not correct play that is a
little bit illegal have he had grounds
for complaint but hey look when you're
playing against your roommate you don't
say dude's a gentl and you know what yes
had Reay actually adjusted the pieces on
his time he would have been flagged
because he would have lost on time so uh
Wesley just chill he didn't he didn't
call it but there that was a he could
have he could have said excuse me that's
what happens in that case if Wesley
would have called does he get an
additional minut what happens it's the
arbiter's decision the Arbiter can sit
there and say you know
what felt a little bit wrong I'm going
to penalize by giving your opponent an
extra minute and everybody would have
said Square Fair Square what have we got
Peter it looks to me like wle much
better for white the question is whether
he can put it away uh this Knight on B7
the pawn structure is Terri inclusion of
Rook A4 as well Rook A4 might be
provoking A5 and then everything is
going to hang everywhere I like Rook G1
as well just reminding Ray that this
Rook is also in the game might go to G5
somehow white slipped in B3 as well very
nice little inclusion for the
King and really getting very panicky
with the way he's making the moves you
can feel the speed the pieces beinged in
the middle of the square the nervousness
and by the way I mean again as we
started this game Wesley was so
despondent he just had this body struck
posture of like oh what was me uh let's
play Blitz tomorrow everybody but he has
played a very impressive Game King to by
the way but he's now under a minute
himself and are leveling out and has he
given Ray a chance to play Rook e four
yes he has and he does uh that was
a i i really expected the tempo move
Rook g g G5 to come because now there is
no Rook G5 the bishop is hanging so
trades tr's still he's still going to be
better but yeah I would have tried
avoiding any trades at all I think
precisely conversion is going to be
harder with every piece coming off and
now Queen D4 is even something that you
have to consider on the next move no
question about it even the end games are
going to be very very unpleasant for
black but uh it's easier to play on 10
seconds if you had Rook G7 we'd be all
smiles right but it's not there the
bishop is hanging you don't have time to
put pressure on the C7 pawn and now
Wesley just falls back from that
diagonal and you can get a feel that
something has gone wrong
for Queen D4 Queen D4 and then Rook G5 I
guess and the H5 Pawn is so weak that
this is still going to be a massive
massive problem for Ray if you play Rook
h8 Rook takes C5 by the way is a very
cute geometrical motive Rook h8 Rook
takes C5 that is cute because the queen
eyeballs but we do have Rook with Rook
attacking that Bishop on D2 so Ray
continuing to play active chess
absolutely but it does allow a check on
G8 but how dangerous is that check so
long as the Queens are coming off I
wouldn't describe it as a dangerous
threat so I'm I have no desire to help
your your Pawn structure so Bishop came
back to C1 but Ray got his Rook to
E2 play Rook to E1 and you want to pick
up that Queen and take snap up that Rook
but it's illegal because it's uh the
King on B2 is pinned so there is a pawn
there is a Pawn on uh pre as we would
say queen takes D4 Rook takes H5 uh
there's no longer the bishop the bishop
being
protected you're absolutely right and
the H Pawn is the strongest passer
against the Knight so in the end game
it's extremely difficult for a knight to
actually fight against the H Pawn Rook
takes C5 you mentioned Rook
h8 as being a g three seconds for Ray
Robson and he makes a move with just one
second on the clock you
mentioned and Onish Gary's first loss in
the event as Ali Raza comes back uh a
very geometrical move there Rook TI a
nice find Ray Robson now down a pawn and
this should be winning this should be
winning yeah this even with the with the
equal material this end games often
become quite torturous for the side with
the Knight because of how better the
bishop is at touch positions yeah
exactly Wesley having one of the worst
tournaments did I just 11 seconds yes
it's been it's happening for the last
two moves yes
yes just playing moves on one second but
I was saying that Wesley playing one of
the worst tournaments one of the most
difficult challenging tournaments he is
he's playing like a boss and it looks
like he's going to play spoiler to ra is
any any of the contenders winning uh
Anish lost that's a good question Anish
lost who else was tied for mvl is not
winning and Liam and Liam is also not
winning so he's still going to win the
tournament despite the loss in the last
round seemingly he might not even need a
draw that's just how well Ray Robson has
played the tournament uh I didn't
understand the move Rook H5 D4 seemed
cleaner yeah Rook D4 was the absolute
but Bishop
G5 KN a five now this is becoming a bit
tricky it's still winning I'm pretty
sure but yeah the pawn on H4 should have
been gone off the board by this point of
course and Knight F5 keeps it alive
Knight F5 and I have to say that Wesley
has been playing pretty all Tempo too I
mean he's a where that Ray's clock is
under great duress but
he's he's played fast but now 30
seconds by the way uh uh Fabby beat
Jeffrey Jan yeah we thought he had a
nice Advantage we just didn't know how
great it was um attacking the C7 pawn
and ala as you mentioned beat Anish a
nice game by Ala with the black pieces
from start to finish there very good uh
C5 another 1
second this is remarkable Rook takes A7
Rook e three though uh we had enough
with this Pawn but now hang on time to
play no because you're going to pick up
the H3 Pawn how dangerous is this H Pawn
I go back to H7 on 20 seconds pretty
annoying I would say really cuz I got
Bishop C7 check too it doesn't go to H2
so I go Rook H7 you go Rook H3 I go A4
oh let's do it 10 seconds Rook F7 chosen
Rook F7 because the Knight moves then
you go Rook H7 but he's going to go King
H Pawn H Pawn is hanging H Pawn is
hanging so do you go King E6 you have to
and now we go Rook F6 check King E5 and
then we go after the C5 Pawn starts with
Rook C7 oh pardon me he did not include
my my bad I was about to include The
Rook to um F6 check he played Rook C7
immediately King D6 is he going to
repeat with Rook F7 will he bail out or
will he play for more oh I'm sure he
will oh he repeats once and he changes
it up with Rook F6 King E5 only moov so
what's the plan now for Wesley exactly
what is the plan for Wesley the plan is
easy for Ray and he's managed to get
some seconds on the clock H3 Pawn is
falling and the H Pawn will start
punching down the board exactly do you
just start pushing the air Pawn
yes yes do you go he first moves The
Rook out of the the attack he can still
Chase The Rook with King
D5
and we do have Rook F6 check King in the
meantime MBL Drew against samian and
yanish is completely winning against
Leon Liams so Rook C8 okay so his
intention is you go ahead and take the
pawn we go Bishop B6 we pick up on C5
and then that is exactly his intention
correct
yes but then the dream would be for
white to sacrifice the bishop for the h
Pawn at some point because it also three
versus knight KN yes rook and three
pawns connected pawns quite a mess Rook
a KN it's a game for three results this
one time is ticking though how how is it
that Ray four three oh my God make a
move he just got a knight D6 uh with C4
check wins the C5 Pawn right now and
he's reaching for it he does I think Ray
missed this one Ray missed C4 yes C4 if
you move your king we have Bishop F6
check and we drive the king away from
the protection of the C5 Pawn so not The
Rook is attacked you don't have time to
take H4 so he's going to pick up the C5
Pawn you take on H3 and then and then
where do you put your rook and then
you're winning Rook takes and you put
your Rook behind Rook H5 there still
Knight F5 and then you start pushing on
the queen side cuz the H Pawn doesn't
really run very far with the Rook on H5
it will be very very difficult to's
reaching for his Aon he says I don't
even don't even need to put the Rook on
H5 push him baby push him baby that's it
Knight B7 but Rook D5 is still I
wouldn't have been allowing KN B7 but I
agree with you I I somehow that Bishop
is a very impressive uh uh stalwart
stopper of the you can tell with their
body language is a bit panicky he
collapsing well he knows he's losing yes
which is once you okay you once you've
reached that understanding I'm lost okay
now you can put yourself in you know
Cheapo mode get that KN to C2 with a
check could be a cheaper mode but it's a
bit far away off Knight is coming off
the board Bishop C7 is a very nice touch
just preparing to take uh to take the
Knight he will just take on D6 now play
Rook H5 play King B4 and then the
position wins itself exactly you no
longer really need to think about and
very clean very clean I would probably
include a rook check don't ask me why
just take the extra 10 seconds thank you
very much and put my king on B4 and then
uh Ray will resign yes and you want to
put there's actually a little bit of an
Intrigue left because you don't want to
be converting a and C uh so once H2 King
before happens and by the way you saw
that Ray just kind of made the move like
a knuckle board knuckle ball you
actually don't resign here I don't think
because I think you can pick up the the
B3 Pawn for the pawn on H2 I think you
actually continue or at least you you
you ask your opponent to show because
let's say I put the King on B7 how do
you how do you make progress without
abandoning the B3
Pawn Yeah just do this just do this and
pause and by the way the good news yeah
for re Robson is that none of the
players who were in on nine points
actually catch up with him because nepo
has won his game against Lake Wang Liam
Anish loses Liam loses and the third
player Maxim V lra drew his game so Ray
Robson regardless of what happens is the
winner of the St Louis absolutely he
will he will have the the good news soon
but so far he doesn't know it yet yeah
A6 King B8 and then Rook R H7 and
A7 you have to abandon the H Pawn but
you're right I don't want to play A and
C Pawn you absolutely don't yeah no no
but uh A7 A6 is the move King A8 yeah
and now after King B can even go A7
seven checking 8 C5 but then are there
any ideas of um stal M no you you can't
stal no C5 on the board now as Ray is
about to play King A8 and then we're
going to see A7 and probably and
probably resignation yeah and there you
go and you've got to move your Rook away
and then he just picks up the H2 pawn it
it it's backing his way into first place
but it's first place nonetheless still a
deserved first place I feel uh he will
still be the only person in the
tournament having who who's won three
games I'm pretty sure yep uh so huge
congratulations to Ray who goes into the
blitz portion fantastic fantastic
performance as the winner of the rapid
and for Wesley an important win before
the blitz absolutely you have this
difficult tournament and then you end on
the note of taking down the champion of
the rapid it gives you confidence to go
into Blitz no question about it a
victory es especially when you're you're
you're off form and nothing has gone
right I mean it really the Sun starts
shining the birds start chirping life is
better S see the rains but I'm wondering
if this is the curious case where you
know Ray Robson goes on to become the
champion of the rapid in any case Wesley
gets a win in the last round it's a bit
of a
win-win yeah well if you're in rues
you're very happy that you're you're the
victor of the do you think he knows not
yet no he hasn't looked up yet and I'm
not sure they have screens that allow
them to watch all four all four of the
other games so I I think he's still
feeling dejected and worried and worried
that he's uh uh left something on the
table I think the I think the word
dejected is exactly it I mean you know
uh that is the face of dejection we're
seeing right now I'm trying to think I'm
sure it's happened that I won a
tournament by losing my last round game
and I didn't feel good about winning the
tournament hor
it's absolutely horrible it spoils it
spoils the feeling of the tournament so
much and that is it it's h Wesley gets a
win Ray Robson loses but wins the rapid
congratulations to Ray very very well
played but we still have 18 games of
chess for all of these people starting
from tomorrow and for Wesley he just
played a boss game this is the Wesley so
that we've come to expect over the years
where has he been where's he been yeah
like just suddenly made an appearance
for the first eight rounds of this
tournament the dragon has broken up and
we will head over to our players as
Anastasia is with a special
guest yeah thank you guys I have ala
with me I know that it was a shaky day
today and not everything went really
right but at the end you won the game
against sish gir and I think it was
really brilliant game with so much
tactics can you show us what happened
and um some critical moments there were
few sure in this game yeah um I was very
like tilted here so I just was making
moves explain why because the previous G
the previous game I cannot lose the end
game I don't know how I lost the game
but s seven years it was crazy I was
watching it yeah but yeah it happens but
yeah this game I didn't I just was
making moves to finish it rapid but um
suddenly it got interesting so I got
interested in the game because uh yeah
here again I blundered Queen B5 Knight
A7 I have to go back yeah but yeah
again
um
here he could have gone B5 directly
because if I take he just
takes yeah and if you take and take Rook
B8 and he takes on B2 he has very good
position mhm so I it didn't make so much
sense Rook but probably he missed before
so and now I have play G4 here
I think it's very interesting I think
it's about engine will probably show
it's around equal but um it's always
tush position so yeah did you expect
this bishop before or you calculated
only Bishop I only calculated Bishop
before in two 3 seconds and then I saw
Knight A2 at least so I just played G4 I
didn't calculate anything else so he
just to he thought that I'm in really
bad shape so it's probably I'm
blundering everything I see okay he
wanted to punish you again he was sure
I'm in a very bad shape 82 982 yeah I
hear but still I don't know if I'm much
better here because I couldn't find yeah
so no I think you were following this uh
the line which is like the main line so
you took on C6 yes Rook A4 he told me
Bishop H7 after but okay it's very small
detail and here I think there was
something yes instead of maybe he could
have taken on d8 somewhere um yes C3
okay this is the main he has to push I
couldn't so here I wanted to ask you
about this move Rook C8 because let's
say your Rook is defending the Knight
and then you also Tred to take this Pawn
let's say or or it was against Rook C4 I
was just trying to not allow Rook c45 I
see ah this was the idea yes so Rook C8
but maybe it's not the best move because
let's say the computer suggested Rook C1
let's say was the same or less idea Rook
C4 I could and um here maybe Rook B8 or
yes or maybe
yes so or possible but let's say in the
game it was Rook C8 and yeah F4 Bishop
E4 is only move what was your feeling
around here like C2 was very worried I
said I could lose the game easily also
but um I think he could just go Knight
D7 to make draw I think yeah I think it
was also the suggestion of the computer
yeah because I can because he's playing
Knight B6 Knight D7 so if I take take D5
he just goes Knight B6 mhm he probably
he missed that this is okay for black
yeah you still can take on C because
Rook C1 Rook B1 uhhuh Rook B1 yes and
you don't have the bishop anymore and
you have to take and he takes the Knight
okay but but even here I think uh also
okay probably C1 Knight D6 Rook
B8 I don't think Knight C4 is correct
yeah Knight C4 I think is fine I think
Knight D3 was was an issue because I
mean probably he missed your move Knight
C6 huh what do you think I think he
missed the mating that he saw Knight C6
but he missed that this what he said yes
I I think so he didn't tell me so
probably Rook B2 B2 and to make sure the
Rook is safe yes so you don't have
Knight C6 now yes you then I should go
probably for this and then Rook B7 mhm
takes and takes on C2 yeah I'm better
you're better yes but still pone up but
probably it's he could hold like this
Knight D6 mhm E5 Knight F5 and he makes
some block it but okay I was not worried
about this because at least I push what
a beautiful mate you found at the end so
how far did you calculate it I was
wondering I thought first time mate him
here look F7 yes HG and I think he draw
here suddenly like I couldn't find
Knight C4 what to do here I yes like
Bishop is3 you don't have anymore yes H4
H5 is working or not I'm not sure I'm
really curious yeah it doesn't show that
much G6 wow King G King H6 Rook f8 wait
oh my gosh with some okay it's to too
complicated yes I think this how it's
made oh King F3 I miss King F3 oh so you
saw Rook G1 yeah yeah Rook G1 King F3 I
missed okay this because I have to
calculate Knight D2 King F4 yeah okay
because it covers no c one wow what a
Checkmate see it's not so easy to find
it with how many minutes you have like
one minute two minutes right at the
moment yes so you play but this is also
winning so three is the easiest way yes
the human way yeah you just make sure
that this queen is taken and then you
just give a Checkmate after yeah this is
made so this is made so he resigned um
so um now how do you feel about let's
say today's today and actually yes
that's what you said is very interesting
that you were like tilting in the last
round but things went different and now
what about the blit part yeah yeah I'm
just I'm happy that I'm down just I
think two points if no I don't know if
anyone catched Ray mhm but if no one
catch at the moment no I think he's
nobody man so it's just two points I'm
happy that it's just two points but it
will be a tough day tomorrow because um
I have to catch up two points but still
I catched up this kind of things before
in bled so I like my chance good but I
think y has question for for you yes
Anastasia uh please tell Ali Raza that
yesterday we soared he played the game
of the tournament against Wesley so but
it wasn't a victory could he elaborate
on his thoughts about his game with
Wesley so from
yesterday yeah so there was a he Yer is
asking you about the game from yesterday
against Wesley so what do you think
about this game oh yeah this this game
if I would have won the game it would
have been very nice game
but it still a nice game but yeah
unfortunately I couldn't finish the and
but yeah the yes this queen of five
sacrifice was just brilliant yes he
didn't the most interesting part was he
didn't expected it was like shocking for
him absolutely but he played it amazing
after like H5 and but okay he it's
really hard to play over the board for
him and he blundered but yeah then it
got messy I should have won but yeah it
was very very cool game yeah I think
your your brother now is doing some
podcast and he's analyzing your games
afterwards did you pay attention he's
he's streaming on Twitch I think he's
kind he's analyzing my
games he's always doing this so it's
good people go check him out also yeah
yeah it's nice do you feel some support
this year he's not with you here in St
Louis last year he was here with you
yeah yeah they were all here but now I
just came with my father so but yeah he
he's very interested
in
always commentary make commentary for my
games yes that's for sure he's your best
supporter thank you so much ala and all
the best of luck for you tomorrow thank
you thank you Anastasia thank you Ali
Raza indeed that game with Wesley so
that is phenomenal but the Rapids are
finished Tanya and this is how when we
have a winner of the rapid and it is Ray
Robson a clear winner with 11 points and
tied for a second and in second position
Fabiano Carana with 10 points Maxim V
lra also with 10 the weaky Fabiano uh in
Blitz and Rapid is in second place it's
a very funky looking final cross table
because only two people are in minus
it's only two people are in minus half
the field is on 50% as well which is not
something you see very very often after
four decisive results in the last round
but tomorrow it all starts again a
different competition all together Tanya
time God it's Friday we got Blitz coming
up and it will be n games of Blitz
action and day two another nine games
it's 18 points at Stakes for the player
before we have an eventual winner of the
St Louis rapid and Blitz whatever plans
you've got on cancel them out it's going
to be a lot of fun with the blitz coming
up I love the Ali Raz is saying I'm so
happy I'm only be behind by two points
Peter final thoughts of this
Rapids very very happy for Ray I think a
very deserved winner he will feel a lot
lot better about his final game now that
he knows that he's won the tournament
but bring on the blitz I think the
people are very nicely warmed up by now
I think the last couple of rounds are sh
yeah every everybody is sort of finding
their form and also getting properly mad
at themselves and their opponents and
now there will be a way to express it
two days of two days of Blitz should be
a perfect perfect opportunity for all of
them so bring it on action action action
coming your way as we say good night to
uh very eventful Rapids we'll see you
all tomorrow for the blitz thank you for
joining us tell your friends where
you're hanging out and we'll see you all
[Music]
tomorrow
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is
prohibited